I didn't prepare any background.
I didn't prepare any BGM for this part.
Hey!
Hello!
Welcome to the Void!
Hi!
We are in the Void!
Where is the stinky cat?
I kicked her out.
I kicked her out because she is too stinky.
She stinks up the whole room.
Himito, I like your face.
Thanks?
Do you have a pet?
If you have a pet, I like your pet.
It's like when you go to a friend's house.
I only went to one party before.
Like a school party.
I only ever went to one.
They did not have a cat or a dog or anything!
And it was torturous!
It was the worst ever.
But, yeah.
She went to a party?
I know.
I went to one party.
And my friend, she got really drunk and I held her hair while she threw up in the toilet.
And then I was like, I should go home.
So, yeah.
That was time.
Only the one time I ever went to a party.
What's the point of a party if you can't show off your pet?
That's what I'm saying.
I feel like if you host a party, you have to have a pet.
For any introverts that venture onto the premises.
Because, otherwise...
What am I going to do?
Talk to people?
My friend, she was like doing shots.
And I'm like...
You guys want to watch anime?
I think they were playing Smash though and I just watched that.
For like the two hours I was there.
It's my friend Valentine's birthday.
Could I get a happy birthday for him?
Sure!
Also, Andregos, thank you for the 20 gifted.
Valentine, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Valentine!
Happy birthday!
Yeah!
So today guys...
I have a couple of Playstation demo discs that I'm going to play.
I have two PS1 discs and two...
Originally I thought they were all PS1 discs.
But I have two PS1 and two PS2 discs.
So...
I have several of these.
One of these I like played a ton.
Oh my gosh, I could tell you...
Sorry, I have to explain a little bit.
The stream is kind of my own selfish desire to play the demo of this game.
Because I don't want to play the full game.
I only want to play the demo version again.
Because I loved playing the demo version so much of this one game.
Is it a great game?
No.
But did I love that game?
Yeah, I did.
So, I have that that I'm going to play.
She's going to take us back to the past.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
You know, bust out your CRTs.
And get some Pizza Hut.
And tell your friends that this weekend you're going to have a water balloon fight.
You're going to get your Nerf guns.
You're going to go outside.
Oh my gosh.
Things that children don't do anymore.
This OG sign is looking forward to a trip down memory lane.
I remember having MGS1 and Final Fantasy 8 demo discs.
Yes!
PlayStation 1 tasting menu, if you will.
Well, two of them are PlayStation 1.
But yes.
And one of them...
One of these I got more recently.
I wonder why.
But when we get to there...
You'll of course know why.
And then...
Hold
on.
When I was going through...
I have all my games on a shelf.
And when I was going through everything, I was like...
I didn't even remember...
I knew I had...
When I saw this disc, I was like...
Oh my gosh.
I remember this.
And that's when I was just like...
Wait, this is PlayStation 2 though.
So...
That's when I was like...
I don't have just only PlayStation 1...
Demo discs.
I also have this PlayStation 2 one.
And then also...
I have the Holiday 2004 demo disc.
Which if you are not aware...
I am aware.
Don't worry.
The Holiday 2004 demo disc for the PlayStation 2...
Has a...
A little bit of a bug on it.
Where if you play one of the games called Beautiful Joe 2...
It will wipe your entire memory card.
So we are just not gonna touch that one.
But I was so shocked that I...
Actually, I don't remember playing this one so much.
And the other one, I have no idea what's on it.
So when we get to it, we'll get to it.
Actually...
No, yeah.
Only this one.
I'm sorry.
I'm purposefully not saying the name of it yet.
Since I want it to be a surprise, I don't want to say the name of it.
And then someone will be like...
That CD has...
Schmitty's Grand Adventure.
The best game ever.
You know?
I want it to be a surprise.
Yeah.
And then of course...
Oh my gosh, I'm excited for the Holiday demo disc.
I don't remember ever playing this one.
This might be...
I don't think this is mine.
I might have acquired this from...
My sister's boyfriend.
Because I don't think my dad ever played this either.
My dad was not a PlayStation person.
He was a PC person.
I guess it's yours now.
I guess it's mine now.
Well, you know...
I was about to say something so bad.
But this other one...
I don't remember what's on it.
I'm very excited.
Hopefully...
These discs are scratched to hell and back.
So hopefully we don't have...
Very many problems.
Hopefully.
Well, not technically a demo disc in the traditional sense.
When I remember a demo of Star Wars Battlefront 2 on the second disc of Revenge of the Sith DVD.
Wow!
Had to load it on the OG Xbox.
That's so awesome!
I wish...
I wish we had more demos and games.
I guess we don't really...
I still like buying physical media.
So...
You know, I think it's like...
I guess kind of a lost art.
And you know, you can...
Demo things sometimes on...
Like, you know, Steam will have like free demos.
Or some stuff like that.
But there's always just like...
A...
It's...
There's some sort of excitement when you receive something.
And it's not something you picked out.
You know what I mean?
Like...
If I go to Steam right now and I download the demo for a game.
I found the game and I saw it after...
You know, the demo.
Right?
So it's a little different.
Whereas, if I were to get a demo disc.
I have no idea what's on it.
And so...
I'm gonna be like...
Wow!
This is...
This game that I didn't expect I would like.
Is actually so awesome!
So...
You know, I'm very excited to try this out.
And kind of go down memory lane with you guys.
Totally agree.
Yeah!
It's fun, right?
So let's be boomers today and...
Have a fun time.
Let me start up...
Okay.
The first one that we're doing is the one that I mentioned earlier.
Which is like the one that I played a ton of.
Oh my god, I played...
I even still...
I still have the little paper case that it came in.
I treasured this demo disc, okay?
I don't think you guys understand.
Like, I...
I actually liked it so much.
I still have it, like...
You know...
So, I don't even know where I got this from though.
I don't know if it was from a magazine.
I know some people said they got stuff from...
Got discs from Pizza Hut back in the day, but...
I don't remember ever getting a Pizza Hut one.
Demo discs are like a box of chocolates.
You never know what you're gonna get.
PC magazine or Sony magazine?
I do have a...
Not PC, sorry.
P...
Wait, no.
I have one from...
PlayStation magazine.
Yeah.
And I think all of these go...
Let's see.
I have one that goes...
What's on this one?
Oh no, I'm not gonna look.
I only know one game that's on this one.
Am I making it too obvious?
Okay, I'm gonna start my PlayStation now.
I was having some issue with the sound earlier, so...
Ah!
Good, good, good, good.
Yay!
Wait, it's in there, right?
Oh boy!
Oh my gosh, it's so...static-y.
Oh my God.
Wow!
I've been cho...
Chosen?
Wow!
The PlayStation Underground.
Oh my God.
I've been chosen.
I can't read anything.
Experience the PlayStation Underground CD magazine.
2 CDs per issue.
4 issues a year.
8 discs with playable demos.
Oh my God.
Interviews with the game makers.
Behind the scenes of PlayStation events.
Hints, downloadable codes and more.
Hints and codes?
Be the first to get information on the next generation of PlayStation.
And see what you've only been hearing about.
Is that sad?
Finally, a magazine that doesn't make you read.
Everything is so crunchy.
Call 1-800-983-SONY.
I can call Mr. Sony?
No way.
I can call Mr. Sony!
As a PlayStation Underground member, you now have access to all the inside information on Gamer Kadrima.
Guys, we're in.
I don't think I ever got these issues.
I think...
I think this was a gift from somebody for Christmas or something for me.
Yeah!
Welcome to PlayStation Underground TM.
So this one has Spiral Year of the Dragon.
Crash Bash.
Grind Session.
MLB 2000.
This is the one I wanted to play!
Disney's The Emperor's New Groove.
The video game!
Yay!
Okay, first... Okay, you only play... That's the last level that you play, is the one in the jungle.
But the first one you play is in the village.
And then you go to my favorite part, which is the rollercoaster.
And then you go to the third level, which is that, which is the jungle.
But my favorite is the rollercoaster.
Spoilers.
Matt Hoffman's Pro BMX.
MediEvil 2!
Jarrett and LeBont Stock Car Racing.
What is with like the strange typefacing on the... Why is it so... There's such strange spaces here.
Yeah, MediEvil.
I actually never played the original MediEvil.
And I never played MediEvil 2 fully, but I played the heck out of this demo.
And it also scared me a lot.
Sydney 2000.
I didn't play most of these.
Okay, I also never played the Spider-Man one.
Well, I say never.
I did not play Spider-Man very much.
NFL Game Day 2001.
Cool Borders 2001.
NCAA Game Breaker 2001.
No way.
The Legend of Dragoon.
Wait, Dragoon is trademarked.
Jokeyboon.
I think you better be careful.
Threads.
What was this one?
Why does that look like Lara Croft?
Well, yeah, there's a good amount of...
Good amount of variety.
There's too many sports.
Too many sports in this one.
I'm complaining.
I'm calling Sony right now and I'm complaining.
Too many sports.
Boo sports.
I didn't really play any of the sports ones.
Oh my gosh, I want to play this one.
Oh my gosh.
I'm not going to start with this one.
I will... Okay, actually maybe I will.
I'll play up until the end of... We don't have to play this level.
I can play up to like the end of the...
The end of the...
Rollercoaster.
Okay, sorry.
Wow!
Okay.
Just noticing that... Hold on.
My thing is a little off.
Hold on, I'm going to do this.
I'll just go widescreen.
Thank you.
Sorry that some of the text was cut off.
There we go.
I'll just go... Actually, I'll just go smaller.
Okay.
There we go.
It looks better?
Cool.
Rating pending.
Oh, what do you think they're going to rate this?
The Emperor's New Groove video game.
What do you think?
What do you think they'll rate this?
Em...
Empermita!
Wait, okay.
L2, R2 is move camera.
L1, rotate camera.
I didn't press anything.
Did it send me back?
Oh.
It was like, hey gamer, what are you doing?
You got to press the button.
Gamer!
Frontal kick and pick up and release pots.
Turned him into a llama.
Funniest thing I've ever seen.
Says the alpaca.
Okay, you know what?
We'll figure it out.
We're gamers.
Oh my gosh, PlayStation demo is loading.
This is crazy.
Can you play as Kronk?
No.
No, but you can see his pregnant wife.
Oh my god, we're just watching the movie!
Oh my god!
The groove.
I'm sorry, but you threw off the Emperor's groove.
I'm sorry!
Oh wow!
Oh my god!
Llama!
Oh my god, Kronk!
I love this movie.
Demon Llama!
Yeah, there should be no DMCA, right?
It's like watching a trailer.
Probably.
Oh no.
Guys, don't worry so much about it.
It's okay.
Oh my god, this is like the longest trailer ever.
They're just spoiling the whole movie.
Oh my...
How silly.
Oh my god!
Bad Llama?
Why is he so...
This too is Yaoi.
Yaoi.
Kuzco is always just a little like...
I know what you are, Kuzco.
Do you ship them?
No, that would be NTR.
He has a pregnant wife.
We can't do this.
Look at me and my bathtub.
Doom Yaoi.
It's so sad.
I can't even read the copyright.
It's so crunchy.
Bring it on.
In theaters?
I don't think I saw it in theaters.
I don't know when I saw this movie.
2,024 years ago.
Craziness, huh?
Disney Interactive.
Do they still call themselves that?
Disney Interactive?
Argonaut.
I get it.
Did you know Kuzco's name in the first draft of the script had to be changed when Japanese localizers pointed out them?
No way.
Seriously?
Oh my god.
Guys.
Slideshow.
What the hell is this?
Maybe I shouldn't have clicked it.
Oh.
Emperor Kuzco having turned into a llama may have serious implications on his plans for Kuzcotopia.
Pacha.
A lowly peasant.
Strong, honest, faithful.
But most of all, he has no fear of talking llamas.
Continue.
Press X to continue.
Oh.
Kronk.
Yzma's devoted partner.
He's not very smart, but he can do great things with spinach puffs.
Yzma.
Kuzco's mutinous aide.
Her single aim is to get rid of Kuzco and take the throne for herself.
If only she could master those transformation potions.
Press X to continue.
Oh my god.
Tipo and Chaka.
Who the hell are these guys?
Oh, they're the kids.
Can their father, Pacha, save the village from Kuzcotopia?
Helping the emperor may be the only way.
Only together can this unlikely alliance save the day.
Kuzco and Pacha must defeat Yzma, save the village, and find the antidote to restore the emperor to the throne.
I like how it has to like... reset every time.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Yo, we're zooming there.
Guys, we have to collect all the coins.
Wow, the village.
Chapter 1.
Wow, they're showing us the whole place.
What are these?
Oh, I can't get these yet.
Hey there, buddy.
Let's go.
I want to get away from this village, out of this body, and back to my palace so I can build Kuzcotopia.
I can't show you the way out of the village unless you build Kuzcotopia somewhere else.
I don't make deals with peasants.
Damn.
Then I guess I can't take you back.
Fine, I'll find my own way back.
No, it's far too dangerous.
Just wander around by my hut.
I've placed rocks and pebbles to show where the lethal...
The lethal drops?
What does that mean?
Why is he like...
La la la, not listening.
And don't take the villagers' coins.
The villagers are my people, so those are my coins.
He's so real for this.
What do you mean by the lethal drops?
Oh my gosh.
Oh god, the camera.
I can't help but take your money if you're just gonna...
If you're just gonna leave it by the cliff.
Maybe put it in your pocket.
Oh my gosh, the camera is whack, you guys.
I think these are for later.
Can I go inside?
No.
Do a flip.
Let's take this kid's money.
Oh hey kid.
By pressing your action button, you can smash these red pots.
Good, I feel like smashing something.
Guys, smash or pass?
Hell yeah.
Did I get all of these coins here?
I think so.
Is there anything up top here?
No.
There's an annoying kid though.
Oh, he's running around.
Can I help you kid?
Wow, this is actually... Oh my god, the lag.
I feel like this could look worse, right?
I feel like this could...
look worse.
The lag is real.
How did I deal with it?
This is a secret.
Guys, I remember.
I'm also killing...
I didn't want to...
Oh my gosh, I already lost a life?
Oh shoot.
I don't think I'm gonna make it.
Karma?
I'm the emperor.
There's no karma.
Oh wait, this is the checkpoint.
I should have done that before.
You think I got... Wait, you think I got all these coins before?
Oh yeah, I have 10.
Let's go back in.
What if they're like... I don't know.
Evil or something.
And it refilled our life.
Perfect.
Guys, do you think we should play this?
Do you think this is gonna be game of the year?
In 2001?
Pinto, it's my birthday today!
But I'm stuck at work.
Lava!
Oh my gosh, perfect game for you.
That's okay, because I'm getting a tattoo of Fossful Light from Hosekin Okunidan over the weekend.
Thank you for the Hoka Super!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Oshama Llama!
I hope your tattoo doesn't hurt too bad.
What did he mean by the lethal point?
Still a little concerned about...
I think he needs to explain that better, you know?
Oh my god, there's parkour.
Parkour.
Checkpoint!
Nice.
What the heck is this?
This pad raises the columns to form steps.
Once they're triggered, you better be quick before they lower again.
Ever thought of making them stay up for good when you press the pad?
Bushing?
Don't tell me.
You've got the brains in the family.
Okay, hold on.
We're so good.
Oh, I think this is if I need health.
Game of the Year is the same year FGS2 came out.
Okay, when you put it like that...
I mean...
I mean, when you put it like that...
To open some village doors, you have to put a pot on a pad.
Llamas pick up pots by pressing their action button.
How did you get here so fast?
Hey, it's a game!
Don't get cocky, kid.
Nice.
My personal vote for 2001 Game of the Year is this little indie game called Halo Combat Evolved.
Guys, did you see how many things Astro Bot was nominated for?
Astro Bot sweep?
Except they'll probably win none of them, but that's okay.
This could be Metal Gear Solid 2, I'm just saying.
To charge, press your charge button.
When you're running, collect llama potions to replenish your red charge bar.
A lethal drop means...
A lethal fall from a high place.
Like you dropping from the cliff earlier.
No, I get that.
But like...
What the hell?
Like, why do they have that?
You'll never catch me!
You're really gonna make me do this, aren't you?
Oh, I have to beat up this kid.
Oh shoot.
Oh my god, he just fell from the lethal... Oh, never mind.
Okay.
Guys, I got this.
Where did he go?
Oh my god, the lag.
We got this.
Oh my god, I feel like I'm playing Spyro right now.
I gotta...
Oh my god.
Okay, we got this.
I'm gonna kick this kid's ass!
This kid is besting me!
This kid is one-upping me right now.
You guys!
Okay, hold on.
We're gonna catch him.
Right now!
Come on, kid!
Where am
I?
Oh, I'm here.
Oh, there's a checkpoint right here.
Let's kick this kid's ass.
I'm hearing the Emperor's, Lion's and Snake's voice.
And it surprisingly fits.
I remember playing this game when I was younger.
The dialogue voiceover was hilarious.
Wait, since this is a demo, it has no voiceover?
But the actual one had the voiceover?
Okay, let's get him from the opposite side.
Yeah, kid!
I kicked his ass!
Hey, you've broken my toy llama!
Here, just take my red idol and leave me alone.
So long, kid.
It does work.
Voiceover takes up a lot of disk space.
That makes sense.
God, he really starts like...
Yeah, I'm a bully to that children.
Hello?
Red idol.
Wait, did I grab it?
Maybe I didn't grab it.
Oh, I didn't even take it.
Use red Cusco idols on red Cusco doors.
We're doomed now.
Oh my goodness.
The render distance is something, huh?
Why are there giant mushrooms here?
Are we not...
Wait, huh?
Hey Pacha, don't you ever do any work?
He's so rude!
Cusco, stay away from this ancient tree.
It's very fragile.
That's why we wrote an X on it.
You mean rotten.
It's just old, so leave it alone.
Maybe I will.
Maybe I won't.
Just don't charge around by the tree, okay?
What?
What does that mean?
Why does it have a giant X on it then, Pacha?
Oopsie.
My bad.
I'm just a llama.
Ris...
Okay.
Oh gosh.
Alright, very carefully.
Very carefully.
Nice, okay.
That looks like a secret.
If we charge...
And jump!
Maybe there is another way to open.
Oh wait.
Oh, is this the same thing?
No, this looks like a different area.
Hold on, let's talk to the girl.
Hello little miss.
In this area you will find a Whompie.
My Whompie!
A Whompie is a continue.
If you have a Whompie when you die, you will replay from your last checkpoint.
Kid, how do you know all this?
Beats me.
Aliens are like...
Just...
Oh, I see it!
Aliens are like implanting the information in her brain.
Wait, okay.
Alright.
Wait, what the hell is this supposed to...
Oh.
Okay, I think I'm supposed to...
Go on this?
Oh, they like magically appear!
This place is kinda wack.
Oh my god.
Oh gosh, parkour in this.
The fourth wall.
No, don't worry about it.
Don't worry about it.
We gotta get the Whompie, you guys.
Nice.
Whompie!
Oh, oh my gosh.
Got one Whompie.
Oh my god, why did they put it back over...
To go back you have to go over the ledge?
It's so evil!
That's so evil.
What the hell?
And I don't even keep the Whompie!
This sucks.
You don't even...
What's the point of grabbing the Whompie?
What's the point of grabbing the Whompie if you don't even get to keep it?
Wait.
Oh, oh.
I think I didn't...
Hey Minto, hello!
There we go.
We don't have time for you Whompie.
Hey kid.
Humans can look around by moving their head, but I think llamas have to use triangle.
Don't you have anything better to do?
Use your look button to see the red idol at the top of the statue.
That's not, that's not an answer.
Little kid.
Little kid, that's not an answer.
What's this guy?
What are you doing?
The wrong button.
Nice.
What's old man Jenkins doing?
Is he supposed to be an enemy?
Do I kill him?
Please unlock the full game for the Whompie.
No, I think...
I think I could've used the Whompie, but I also...
Don't feel like dying.
Why is it so evil?
Why is the, why are the platforms above like the...
Oh my gosh, an extra life.
Why are they above the ledge?
It's so evil.
Yeah.
What's this guy even here for?
To make it seem like there's actually people inhabiting this world?
Can I kill him?
I'm an evil llama now.
And then this giant ass flower for no reason.
It's kind of crazy your stamina doesn't replenish.
Charge him?
I tried, it didn't do anything.
Demonic llama.
Where are we going?
Oh, 44 out of 50.
Secrets 1 out of 2.
We know where the other secret was.
But I didn't feel like getting it.
The Whompie.
Alright guys, I have to lock in now.
I have to lock in for the catacombs.
Yeah!
Oh my god, I'm so excited.
Oh my god.
Yeah!
I used to play this one chapter for hours.
I can't even express to you.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm locked in.
I'm so locked in right now.
I'm locked in.
I missed the Whompie.
Sorry.
Guys,
I was not locked in enough.
I totally had that though.
That's so messed up.
Oh my gosh.
My bad.
Why is it that the sound is so horrible?
I forgot how squeaky and terrible the sound.
Maybe we should go for the Whompie.
Sorry, I missed it again.
We're good!
Yeah!
I almost got every coin.
That's the one level I would do so much.
I think it was even muscle memory.
I think it's like burned into my ectoplasm.
Shame the Disney Metal Gear Solid crossover.
I hear this is one of the better Disney games on the Playstation 1.
Do you agree?
I didn't play anything else so I honestly don't know.
Then you go to the jungle, which I don't really like this level so...
There's like this little spider.
There's like the spiders and stuff.
You like Disney's Vampire Zoo group?
Yes.
Help me!
Who's there?
I can't see.
It's getting dark.
Save yourself!
The pain!
Oh my gosh, Metal Gear!
Avenge my life, buddy!
To kill a spider, use your roller charge to flip the spider onto its back and then jump attack its belly.
Ah ok, that was the freakiest thing I've ever seen.
I don't like this level very much.
Where are the spiders anyway?
Hey spiders, where are you at?
Damn, he's got moves.
I think if I press this we can leave.
Ok, perfect.
Discover many other diverse levels seen in the movie.
The treacherous river section.
I've never seen that before.
I've never played this game.
Where you must guide our heroes through rapids, logs and furious crocodiles.
Sounds horrible.
The mysterious city and palace.
Meet the Incan citizens and solve mind bending puzzles.
I don't feel like doing that.
Oh my gosh, the mountain levels hold...
Deep in the catacombs, discover fantastic new transformations.
Including the flying bunny.
Doesn't sound...
High above the city in Yzma's lab, battle strange creatures and conquer the incredible 2D platform race to defeat Yzma.
I'm glad I didn't have to do that.
Sir, we're here for just the rollercoaster.
Thank you.
Yeah, exactly.
I wish the rollercoaster level was like 10 times longer.
I want to play it forever.
I want to play just that level forever.
Graphic design is my passion.
Brought to you by PlayStation Underground.
Well guys, we played the only reason I decided to do this stream today.
So what now should we play?
I always sucked at this one.
Actually I was really... Oh we can do medieval too.
Cinema.
I really sucked at this one and I really sucked at...
The skateboard one.
What is Threads?
Can I see what Threads is?
I'm so... I don't remember this at all.
It's clothes?
Is it like a video?
Looking good is half the battle.
Oh my god.
Wow!
Oh my god!
I can't even tell what these are.
Oh
my gosh, the Gran Turismo jacket is kind of awesome.
I can't... Everything is moving so fast.
I can't see anything.
What is that supposed to be?
Oh, I want the backpack!
Wow!
What is that?
Oh, a bucket hat!
To order call.
What?
888...
What is that?
It's just a pouch?
Oh my god, wait, that's kind of awesome.
What is that?
Oh, shorts.
Win the battle.
Wear the threads.
Wow.
Naughty dog.
I wish they had Metal Gear stuff.
That was kind of awesome.
OK, so we have Spyro, we have Crash Bash.
PS2 demo merch drop!
We have...
We have a grind session.
This is the other one that I was not very good at.
Crash Bash?
I can do the Crash Bash.
Move, fire missile.
That's it?
There's only two controls?
Charge and climb onto arena while in panic arena.
What does that mean?
Here we go.
Universal.
Oh my gosh!
Wow!
This is so...
Takes me back.
League.
Oh, leave game.
I thought it said league game.
I was like, how do you get online?
OK, let's just do adventure mode.
Oh, I can play with two players!
In a demo?
Probably not.
I wonder if I hooked up another controller.
Oh my gosh, wait, I do remember this vaguely.
We can't do Space Bash.
Oh, I think I did Pogo a lot.
Complete all challenges to unlock this...oh.
Nevermind.
Pogo Painter?
OK, here we go.
I'm going into the crashes!
I'm getting sucked in!
Capture colored squares to get the high score.
This is just...this is just crab game.
The loading?
Oh, come on.
It's all good.
Break these boxes to turn your squares into points.
Arrows color whole rows of squares.
Touch missiles to pick up.
Fire missiles.
Oh, OK.
Here I go.
Why?
We're going, we're going, we're...
Oh shoot, I messed that up.
I picked up a missile and I'm gonna use it on...this guy!
Uh oh, I'm not doing very well.
Yeah, oh, nice.
Kind of.
Oh my god.
Die!
Wait, this down here...
No, I didn't do...
OK.
Oh, not nice.
Kill his ass.
I don't know if I'm winning.
Didn't I just pick up a missile or am I crazy?
No, no, no!
There we go.
Nice, nice, nice.
Am I winning guys?
Am I winning?
Oh, I think I'm winning.
I think I'm winning you guys.
Oh no, no, no, no.
Guys, I think I'm gonna win this one.
Guys, I think...
I keep screwing up.
Oh, whoops.
Hey, give me, give me.
No, stop!
Uh oh, uh oh.
Maybe I talked too soon.
No, no, no.
Give me my points.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
OK.
You know what?
Just take anything.
Take anything we can get.
Oh, I think I'm gonna win you guys.
The AI is actually braindead.
Oh, again?
OK, OK.
Cool.
Oh, nice.
I'll take it.
And I'll take that.
And I'll take that, baby.
And I'll take that, idiot.
And I'll take my money.
No, my money.
Nice.
Oh, he has a... he has a...
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Hell yeah.
I never... I had the actual CD of...
What was it called?
The Crash Racing.
I had... Oh my god.
Nice.
Oh my god.
I own like basically half the map.
I didn't need that.
Can another thing, please?
Oh, there.
Nice, nice.
OK.
Hey, you died.
Stop taking... You are my closest enemy.
The doctor guy is stupid as hell.
That guy doesn't know how to do anything.
Give me one last... Yeah.
That guy is dumb as hell.
Mental gaming?
I'm gaming.
How many do I have to do until...
I want to unlock the other game.
Are they ever going to use the...
Well, that explains that question.
I was going to say, are they ever going to use the...
Oh, you jerk.
I like to take the boxes so they can't...
Get more points.
Stop it!
Can a box please drop?
Oh, thank you.
I think they are getting smarter, guys.
How many times do I have to play this game?
I want to demo everything.
Yeah.
Mine and mine and mine and mine.
Dummies.
Big old idiots.
Nice.
Go get this.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
OK, good.
He didn't get the other one.
Yeah, they are absolute chumps.
They are absolute chumps.
These guys don't have a single brain cell.
AI is going to take our jobs?
Well...
I'd like to see these bozos try.
Am I good?
Yeah,
I only played the Crash Racing.
Polar Panic.
Press X button to start.
How do I get the pogo a go-go?
What are all the challenges?
They don't tell me.
They don't even tell me what the challenges are.
Maybe I have to complete this one.
Polar Panic, my beloved.
I don't remember this one.
Gotta play in order.
OK.
Press square to spin.
OK, thanks.
Knock the other players off the ice to win.
Charge the other players.
Cannot charge if meter is empty.
OK, but that's like... It all depends on your mindset, right?
Some people would say that's half empty, but me?
I would say that's half full.
When falling, push into the arena and press square repeatedly.
Pass the weight to other players.
Collect...
Oh, I do remember this one.
Wait, charge the... OK, so we're charging... We're just pressing square, basically.
I feel like I'm gonna lose my brain cells from this song.
Collect lightning from the other... What is this guy supposed to be?
The one on the... Is he an alligator?
But, like, why then does he have... Is he a pig?
I'm so confused.
This demo looks like a bootleg Mario party.
It was the ship when I was like 7.
He's a dingodile.
Dingo and a crocodile.
Did he eat your baby?
Pass the weight to other players.
OK, let's just go for it.
Look at the little polar bears!
Oh my gosh, the Aurora Borealis.
Oh my God!
Oh my God.
This is crazy.
This is insanity.
Oh my God.
Oh my God, watch out.
Watch out for the laser.
Oh my God.
You know what?
Let the girls fight.
Let them fight.
What's that?
What's that sound?
No!
I did it.
I killed a person.
I did it!
I killed a man!
Oh, he's tiny now.
Oh shit, let the girls fight.
The girls are fighting.
Don't charge after me.
Why?
Oh, he just stopped moving.
Don't touch me.
I can't see anything.
It's assault!
No, no, no, please no.
Oh my God.
So you have to not... Oh, I did it.
This should have been top down.
For real, I can't see how far away I am.
Yeah!
So you have to... You want the laser.
You want the lightning bolt.
Why does it make that noise?
It sounds so gross.
Oh my God, no!
I can't see where I am.
They are blocking me.
I can't see.
They are too huge.
I'm just a guy.
I'm just a small little Crash...
Wait.
Oh yeah, I want this.
Wait, do I have to watch the rest of the game?
I have to watch these idiots play?
No way!
Just die... Oh my God, look at them both.
Charge!
Charge item!
Dingo Dial wins!
No!
This one feels too real you guys.
This one feels too real.
Oh my gosh!
Oh no, no, no, no!
I might get charged, but... Nice!
I think I'm too good at this game.
We gamed.
We gamed that.
So good.
I was letting Dingo Dial have his little moment, but...
Where am I?
I can't see anything.
One has died.
Why does it sound like... What the hell?
Oh that's him charging.
Oh shit.
Mintosweet?
What?
What was that?
LOL.
Mint lost to...
What is Pogo a Gogo?
Wait, I... I did... I played your games.
Oh, I have to get the...
I have to get the relic or the crystal.
Which one is it?
Challenges are not fun.
I don't remember ever doing this one, I'll be honest.
You have to do both of them?
All six at the grind?
OK, I think we're good then.
I think Crash was fun.
I think we can go on to the next game.
I think we can go on to the next game, right?
I think we're trying to sample platter everything.
You know, we're just not gonna...
We're not gonna... We don't need to play for so long, right?
But I will do Spyro.
I love Spyro 2.
Ripto's Rage.
It was my favorite, because it was the only one I owned.
I don't know, which... Does this one come in the series?
Like, is it 3?
Or...
I don't know.
This is 3.
Get ready for Spyro's greatest adventure.
Look how cute he... Oh my god!
Oh my god!
Bentley the strong man.
Kick butt as Sheila the kangaroo.
Command the skies as Sergeant Bird.
Monkey around as Agent 9.
Oh my god.
Pilot new vehicles.
Take on the new mini bosses and much more.
Wow, they're selling it.
They're selling it.
Ok, let's not do any swimming levels, because that sounds horrible.
Agent 9's lab.
Ok.
We could try playing as him.
Are you gonna break the demo discs once you're done?
Why would I break them?
Which one should I do?
Stretched out logo?
It really is so stretched out.
It's a gallery shooter.
I'll try Minky.
Break that disc.
If I did that, I wouldn't even have this.
I wouldn't even have this stream if I broke the disc.
5 months of into.
Thank you Urban Canary.
Wow, this is a really long load time.
How much can we sing?
What should I sing?
What song should we sing to see how long these load times are?
Snake Eater?
Do a mix?
I didn't say I am...
I don't...
Flying in the stores!
It
just took that long!
Don't you just press a button?
Well, it didn't tell me that.
Maybe I was supposed to just press the button.
What?
They just advertised the game and then were just like...
You'll have to see!
Let's try one more time.
The adventure continues.
It's a demo speedrun.
It's continuing alright.
The adventure does continue.
They are like, it will continue when you buy our game.
I'll admit they are selling me.
When do we get to the ride?
This is the ride!
Guys, I think it's going to go...
Now!
You gotta put the Konami code.
Up, up, down, down...
Left, right...
A, B, A, B, start?
My trick to make games load when I was young was to not look at the screen.
Oh, true!
Everybody, it's shy.
Don't look at the screen.
Don't look at the screen, ok?
It's shy.
Don't look.
Look away.
Look at me.
Here, hold on.
Look at me instead.
Ok.
It's shy.
So, we are just going to face the other way.
We are going to close our eyes.
Ok.
I'm not looking at it.
Um...
You used up all your Spyro privileges back in 2001.
What if it actually had like a...
Had like a...
You can only play this many times before it locks.
Sort of mechanism.
Stop cheating?
I'm not cheating!
I'm closing my eyes.
Ok, we are meditating.
Are you guys... Do you guys have your eyes closed though?
You guys have your eyes closed?
Guys, I don't think... I think this demo is broken.
I think we can't... I think we are...
We are not prepared for Minky action.
What if they were just like...
Oh, Agent 009 was copyrighted, so...
We have to...
We had to erase this part.
My eyes are open.
Close your eyes!
Nintendo, do that limit demos try?
Does it really?
Smash the... No!
It's also not a Playstation 1, it's my PS2.
Yeah, it might probably is the disc.
The adventure continues.
Or does it?
Does the adventure...
Ok, I want to try one more time.
Because...
I want to try...
If the first level will work.
But...
I think the game is frozen.
I don't remember... How long did it take before to kick us out?
There is something I want to say.
Spiral is really cute.
I like it, I like it, I love it.
I love it.
I finally found it.
Princess, Prince.
Let's live together.
I love you the most in the world.
I love you.
Ok, I'm going to restart it.
There we go.
I polished all of them right before stream.
So I think it's just too scratched.
I think it's just a little too scratched probably.
We get the sound again.
Yeah, you will.
Three more times even.
You will even a couple more times.
What did he tell me to do?
God damn.
PlayStation Underground is...
There we go.
Alright.
This might be a mistake, but...
If it is, it's ok.
If it doesn't work, we'll just...
It threw me off guard.
We even listened to it earlier and I think I was just so shocked by the intro, I didn't even...
Ok, we're gonna...
We're gonna try the first level.
I say Peak.
You guys, it's Peak.
And it's gonna...Oh no.
No, please.
No, Adventure!
Adventure
will continue.
Oh sorry.
Oh my gosh, I got so excited I threw everything up in the world.
Hello!
Oh my god.
Old Spiral.
Oh no.
Top of the mornin' to ya.
The music is kind of awesome.
Oh my goodness.
I kind of remember the controls from Old Spiral, so I think...
I think they're pretty much the same.
Let's try this thing.
Let's get on this thing.
So over here?
Shoot!
Shoot straight, huh?
Big dummy.
You don't even know...
You don't even know how to do anything.
What do you mean it doesn't shoot straight?
I think your eyeballs are on crooked.
Actually, they might actually be on crooked.
Oh shoot.
Maybe don't go head first into the...
Let's shoot the birds.
Can you shoot the birds?
Maybe don't go head first into the guy with the TNT.
Okay, this is as high as it goes.
Okay, that's actually pretty high.
My aim...
I can't tell how...
How high is this?
Oh, that was pretty close actually.
Okay, I think this one needs to be lower and...
What's his flight path?
I can't tell where I'm aiming.
Lower?
Okay.
Lower.
Oh my gosh.
I don't even know if I can kill these guys.
I just want to.
I just want to cause death.
You can.
I think I remember this demo, yeah.
Up one, I think.
There we go.
Nope, nevermind.
That was too close.
Yeah, I enjoy all the killing.
Oh, so close.
There we go.
Nice.
Okay, now we got him.
Why does this feel like already...
Hello?
I can't jump?
Okay.
The white is so blinding though.
It's kind of hurting my eyes, I'm not gonna lie.
Okay.
I like how this game looks exactly like Spyro 2.
Wait, how do I go home?
Can you still do that?
Okay, good.
I still remember the controls.
Yeah, it's pretty hard to look at.
It's hurting my eyes.
Oh, that guy is bad news.
Bad news bears.
I'm gonna charge him.
Oh shoot.
They're all TNT men.
Wait, if I blow fire on... Oh, maybe I'll be fine.
I thought it was the same guy like carrying it before.
Eat my little guy.
Regain your energy.
Flame the boxes?
Makes sense.
Oh, that's a big guy over there.
That's a big guy over there.
For Spyro at the best music?
I don't think I ever played the first Spyro.
I'll be honest.
Okay, we gotta charge.
Can
I not charge these guys?
Just kidding.
I don't remember everything about Spyro.
I'm a liar!
I'm a big fan!
Yeah, give me that.
Give me the... Hello little fairy.
Give me my coins?
Oh, that's weird.
Oh my god!
My guy is dead!
My sparks!
I was like, hey, why isn't anybody collecting the coins for me?
Because he's...
Oh, there's a little guy over there.
He kind of looks like... He's just like a couple of black pixels, but...
If I don't have sparks, I'm dead dead for real.
I wonder what's up there.
What is that?
It takes us back to the beginning.
Fine, okay.
Oh, I almost missed one.
Oh my gosh, I miss having sparks.
He collects all the little gemmies.
It is so hard to see.
No, no, no, no, no!
Oh shit.
I'm gonna die!
So the music for the first Spyros were used for the Amanda show?
No way.
Oh, we got sparks back.
All is well.
Oh, I missed... I don't have any gemmies though.
Okay, let's get this guy before he takes my...
Takes me out.
We'll take him out before he gets me.
This level is so hard on my eyes.
Everything burns.
It burns my eyes.
Frame rate sucks.
It's a Playstation 1.
What do you expect?
I can't believe that this 20 year old technology doesn't have better graphics.
Was the Playstation actually a failure?
More.
Oh shit!
More at 11.
Look, I don't even need these stupid duckies.
How do I get these though?
It's the Spyro 3 disc trilogy from my PS1 as a kid.
I let a neighbor borrow it and they never gave it back and moved away!
No!
My sister's friends would always steal my games too.
So I lost so many.
I had to buy the Kingdom Hearts like 3 times.
Which is quite pricey.
Especially for a kid, you know?
I had to use my allowance every time.
And then I also had to buy the Sims like 5 times.
Because my sister's friends just kept stealing them.
Oh my god.
First Spyro gave me motion sick.
You know what?
That's so fair.
Even this one is kind of making me feel...bleh.
Can I hit that thing?
Maybe I can't.
Nevermind, give up.
How do I get up here?
Maybe from over there?
I love Spyro though.
Are you sure?
I can't hit the eggy?
Nah.
TNT.
Oh, I'll shoot.
How do you...
How do you do this?
I don't remember.
Had one guy steal my Pokemon Blue, Silver, Sapphire, Emerald...
Sadly he was somehow 6'6 and 12 years old.
That guy is just a freak then.
That guy is just not normal to nature.
It's not your fault.
I'm normal.
Everything is fine.
He's immune?
Oh my god.
6 shots.
Let's blow this.
Nice.
One thing I love about Spyro is how many little tiny areas there are to explore.
See, like we can go that way.
So fun.
I'm just gonna go for it.
Well, in the end, it worked.
Let's go this way.
Thank you Sparks.
Met Tom Kenny.
Wait, is he only Spyro from two... Oh, he wasn't Spyro in one.
He seems like a nice guy.
Take him out.
Oh, the bird!
Maynard.
Oh, that's not a bird at all!
That's a dragon!
He's Eevee?
Oh my god.
Wait, from here can we... No.
He's a little Eevee guy.
Oh my homies love Maynard.
That guy.
He's awesome.
Maynard supremacy everybody.
Oh no, no, no.
Move, move, move.
I can't see where I am.
Oh, so close.
Just hit him.
Just hit... Oh, not him.
Hit the other guy.
Spyro, just go!
We got him.
You have fire breath.
The fire breath doesn't work on those guys.
Fire breath, they just go...
It doesn't work on them.
They don't care.
Gosh.
Aren't you a fan of Spyro?
You don't even know that you can't even...
You can't even breath on them?
Can I fly over there?
What if I blow up all of these?
Wait, can I go any lower?
Oh, I can.
Good, now I don't have to worry about it.
Wait.
Oh no.
Don't make me do it again.
Charge and fly?
OK.
Do I have to kill this guy again?
These guys?
OK.
Watch, I'll show you, I'll show you.
See?
It does nothing to them.
They go...
Come here.
I wish I hadn't killed that bird.
What was in that room again?
Oh, that's a gemmy.
I thought it was a lizard.
Fake Spyro fans in the chat!
Fake Spyro!
Look at all these boxes.
What if Solid Snake is under one of them?
Snake, I'm sorry.
Oh, we didn't go into that room yet.
Because we destroyed this.
I apologize for being wrong on the Internet.
You should be!
You should apologize!
You should.
It's OK.
We've all been wrong on the Internet.
Raise your hand if you've been wrong on the Internet.
Help me.
I'm not raising my hand.
Oh wait, I'm raising both of my hands.
But it's like a condition.
I can't help it.
Wait, am I at the end of the level already?
No way.
That's spooky.
Couldn't be me.
Couldn't be me either.
It would be really embarrassing to be wrong on the Internet.
Let's kill these... Wait, aren't these the birds I took out before?
It's too close.
You!
Yeah!
You mixed up the 6 for 9 in Little Misfortune.
You're gonna break that!
That was literally your mistake!
I did nothing!
I was correct!
I was accurate in every time!
OK, there's a lot to go around in here.
Oh, shoot.
I didn't realize it was a drop-off.
Do
they still make Spyro games?
Or did they...
What is this?
The music stopped.
Should I go through it?
They made him like Ikemen and then they... I haven't seen him again.
Just the remake.
I'm going in!
What is this?
Don't crash my game, please.
Who is this?
Piggy?
And Purple who breathes fire.
You're saying all the right things.
Oh my god, look at Spyro's eyes.
They're literally bulging from his head.
He's like...
Did you say Purple and Handsome?
She sounds just like you.
I sure wish I had a partner.
Someone courageous and strong and not a wisp.
Will you please help me perform my ice dance?
My ice dance?
Me and Rhinocaccy players keep hogging the ice and all I want to do is dance.
Well maybe they reserved it first lady.
I don't know what to tell you.
Protect the dancer from evil hockey players?
Yes.
No.
They were like you're too evil to play Spyro.
You even gave the Noah thought.
You're too evil.
I wonder if this one has a time limit.
That's so funny.
The illusion of choice.
I didn't even press anything.
Oh it is timed.
OK.
Watch the Legend of Dragoon trailer.
Is it always a trailer?
Oh it says video.
You're right.
Game was a wisp and took offense to that.
Let's see.
Let's watch the Legend of Dragoon.
The journey that seeks the past ends.
What?
The journey to discover today begins.
Legend of the Dragoon.
An extraordinary...Oh magnificence.
Deception.
Retribution.
Magical combat.
The music is kind of awesome.
Innovative and deeply involving gameplay.
I can't open it.
You have little pixel man being like...
You know what it reminded me of?
You know how when people put characters like Shrek or Edgeworth over top those dogs?
That one dog video of it going through the tubes and everything like that.
It looked just like that.
He was just zooming through those maps.
The music is really great though.
Wow!
That actually looks so good.
Wait, who developed this?
Trademark of Sony.
Legend of Dragoon was ahead of it's time for RPG mechanics.
I love this game.
That's so funny.
I want to see that part again.
I stopped paying attention because I was thinking of the dog.
Dog.
Medieval 2 time?
Yeah!
Let's do Medieval.
Actually, I kind of want to do the skateboarding one real quick and then we'll do Medieval Lost.
If that's okay.
It's so funny.
I love how they are saying all this stuff and not showing any of it.
I can't...
This music is so beautiful though.
I love it.
Here we go, here we go.
Imagine the dog going through the tube.
Tactical combat system.
Collect over 200 usable items, skills and magic.
That's a lot.
Dragon!
Or Dragoon.
Hot girl, transform into Dragoons!
You get to transform into the Dragoon!
Oh my gosh.
It's great.
Items like potions, strong potions, max potions.
We put 197 left.
Alright.
Like I said, let's do grind session and then we'll finish it off with Medieval 2.
Okay, I don't care.
I just want to play for like 2 seconds.
What about Legend of Wisp?
There's no legend.
Oh, Spider-Man?
Oh yeah.
Oh gosh, you guys.
We're going to be here forever if I play every single game on me.
Okay, I'm just going to play for like 2 seconds.
Tournament?
I can't do just training?
Oh my god.
I'm going to be Willy!
My mom has dyslexia and instead of a cat girl I got a rat girl for my birthday.
Problem is I work at the cheese factory.
What?
Day 1.
Kara Beth Burnside.
Damn.
Ed Templeton.
Pigpen.
John Cardiel.
Willy Santos.
Day 1 song.
Kara Beth Burnside.
Ed Templeton.
Pigpen.
Okay, we have to be Pigpen.
Let me select the character.
Guys, I'm scared of this one.
Why did it go back?
Okay, hold on.
Okay, Pigpen.
Oh, I can't choose Pigpen.
He is blacked out.
I can only be Ed or Day 1.
I'm being Ed.
I'm Ed Templeton.
Okay, bio.
What's the bio?
Oh god.
Age.
25.
Give or take.
Year skating.
15.
Blood type.
No idea.
Goofy or regular?
Regular.
Wait, I want to make something like this for Wisps.
Goofy, freaky or regular.
Years as a Wisp.
15.
Height.
6 feet.
Okay, maybe not the super personal questions.
Orange County, California.
Current hometown.
Huntington Beach, California.
Who is your hero?
I try to be my own hero.
Any villains?
Closed minds.
He said that he was regular though.
This guy is all sorts of goof.
Oh, Ed Templeton.
I love you.
You
know what?
That's all I needed to see, honestly.
That's all I needed to see.
Truthfully.
I think we are good.
Okay, Medieval 2.
Oh wait.
Hold on, we'll go back.
Let's do Spider-Man.
Spider-Man first.
I don't remember ever really playing Spider-Man so I have no nostalgia for it.
Regular vs.
Goofy just means which foot you place first on a skateboard.
Oh wait, actually?
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Impact web.
Web yank.
Web dome.
Web spikes.
Kick jump.
Dude, this is so much.
Okay, here we go.
It's a skate term.
I thought it was just like, how's your personality?
I'm regular.
I'm a regular old Joe.
Ed Templeton.
That's me.
I'm just a simple guy.
Some of you guys were saying that this one was actually pretty good.
This game was legit excellent.
Oh damn.
Could Mint Phantom beat Ed Templeton in a skate-off?
No.
But a freak-off?
Probably.
Pretty fun for the time.
Oh nice.
I feel like... I don't know.
I don't know many Spider-Man games but I feel like...
What?
Oh guys...
No!
Guys we keep getting kicked out!
I wanted to actually play it.
I was gonna say, I think most Spider-Man games I've seen have been pretty good.
Okay, let's try Medieval 2.
Please don't...
The worst part is that I don't think this is my even most scuffed CD so...
How about my next one?
Oh this one is actually quite pristine.
I think we'll be good with it.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
This is so nostalgic.
Wow!
This game used to scare the heck out of me.
I could barely play the demo.
I used to be terrified of... enemies.
Once again.
Sir Daniel Fortescue.
Look at his eyes.
I think they are bigger than mine.
Get ready for a scrap!
I... can't... understand... your... accent.
Oh my god.
This running... I can't even stand in your spectral trail.
Fortescue.
Excuse me.
Resume.
Nevermind, I didn't know you'd say the same thing.
I can't skip it.
Just kidding, I can.
Look at me.
Look at me run.
I'm quite limber for someone who just woke up from the dead.
Why do they just have my zombie corpse body on display anyway?
The next bus to Bikini Bottom.
It is said that in times of great need he will return again to free the land from evil.
Well, that's why we are here, huh?
I'm going back to sleep.
Well, actually I would if I...
These camera angles...
At least I can control this one with the... Oh no, it's backwards though.
Why does he stop so abruptly?
What does this say?
Oh my god, it's a hand!
Hello?
Are you my sparks?
Is that my health?
I'm missing an arm!
That's a zombie!
Wait, I have my arm.
It's my weapon.
Ok, hold on, how do I fight?
Oh there we go.
Ok, I'm armed.
I'm armed.
Come here zombie.
Oh there is a lot of them.
It's ok, we'll just take out...
Get
out of here.
I actually scared them off.
I scared them off.
Wait, come back.
Why did you leave?
Oh...
Oh my god, they are fast.
Everything moves so quickly in this game.
I killed one.
Well, he was already dead.
I took care of business.
Oh my goodness, you are in the walls.
Come here!
When do I get my sword?
Hey, don't run away!
He is nuts!
He is just flailing everywhere.
I'm just a patron of the arts.
My bad.
I can't see.
I'm just a patron of the arts.
Found a museum key.
Where did my little hand guy go?
What happened here?
This is ridiculous.
Ok, let's go to the other side.
Oh, I see a spectral trail.
That's disgusting.
I would never leave a spectral trail like that.
That is not something that ghosts are supposed to do you guys.
That's like leaving crumbs everywhere.
It's awful.
Is this my sword?
Yes!
That's like leaving everything around.
It's like horrible, horrible manners.
This guy sucks.
Maybe I should have grabbed this before I went over here.
Oh, I got my arm back.
Let's go.
Can I... The camera is really throwing me a bit through a loop right now.
Ok, I think we have to come back.
For the parkour area.
Oh my god!
Oh,
ouchie ouch.
This is how I protected the city long ago.
Energy vial, nice.
What's this?
A gun?
No way.
Wait, I kind of want my sword back though.
How do I switch?
How do I use this?
L1 Square
Wow!
Oh my god, look at us.
We're so high.
What are you looking at?
It's doing that old video game thing where they would look at things that like...
You're just like, oh, there must be something over there because you're looking at it.
What a charming smile you have.
It's so cute.
Ok, I want my sword back.
He's looking at me.
He's got such a charming little smile.
He is beautiful.
Oh god, don't fall.
A shield?
Why is the audio for this guy so quiet?
Airy
The voice actor really just kind of...
Copper.
Oh, Copper Shield!
How do I use it though?
Oh my god.
Oh, that's the coin.
I mean the key we got.
No, there was some more stuff over here.
Sorry guys.
That's exactly... I can't get used to these controls.
I'm sorry.
There we go.
In here?
And then we go up here?
Why is X to fight and not to jump?
Oh, energy.
Ok, we'll save that for later.
What's over here?
Give me your advice, oh wise ghost.
Please?
Hello?
Oh, there we go.
Dane?
Are these demo discs on actual hardware?
They are!
Yeah!
I did not pay attention to what he just said.
Money baby!
Ok, cool.
Let's just keep going.
Oh, but you gotta sell me now.
Oh, you came!
He put everything...he became like a spider monkey so quickly.
Oh my god.
We are so nimble.
What's this?
Oh god, they are killing me.
Ouch.
I can't just run around as funny as with the other...oh god.
That's actually...oh god.
How do I use my shield?
I just wanna be a little nimble man!
Triangle?
I don't think it worked.
Unless...oh there we go.
Nice!
I dashed!
Coming soon!
I don't even remember where this demo ends.
Like I said, I was always too chicken.
I would see the zombies and I would be like...scary!
Do you wanna buy it?
I rate that a double BOOM!
That was good.
Well guys, this was a good...good amount of stuff.
We got cool borders.
We got these ones coming out.
This is good stuff.
Are you guys ready for the next disc?
OK, give me a second.
Oh yeah, this one is like super duper scraped up.
I guess that's what I get for keeping it in a paper...
In a paper...container.
But this one has like...hold on.
This one has basically no scratch marks on it.
This next one.
Reset!
Yeah, it wasn't in the case.
It wasn't not in the case.
It was in the original little paper sleeve.
But that's OK.
Goodbye!
I wonder if this one has...I've never...I've only bought this one, but I never have like tried it.
I just bought it because I'm a collector.
But I wonder if this one also has an intro.
I'm excited.
Oh this one is also PlayStation Underground!
Let's go!
Sampler.
It's a hot lady.
Oh my god!
Spider!
This is so Indiana Jones.
Is it Tomb Raider?
Everybody is dead here.
Oh good thing there is an exit.
Oh my god!
Wait, we are like in a suit.
What the hell?
I'm cradling my precious PlayStation Underground.
Dude Raider.
Why are we dressed up like 007?
Oh yeah!
PlayStation Underground!
Oh damn.
This guy is beefed up.
Now we are Terminator?
No.
What?
Debriefing.
Spyro the Dragon.
Developers tell all.
Oh my god.
What a transition.
I'm getting whiplash every second here.
I'm very curious.
Well guys, we just did Medieval 2.
Did you know that there is also Medieval 1 on this disc?
But also...
Download station.
Gran Turismo Tekken 3?
What is that one?
I can't read it.
Vice?
Tekken 3.
Oh, Vigilante A.
Project Wormhole.
I love how this is R&D.
Code Archive.
What the hell are these?
The Vault?
What do I pick?
Cheat codes.
Who would do... Hold on.
I want to see the debriefing.
What is this?
He was so gentle about it.
Spyro the Dragon.
I can't read anything.
This guy is such a nerd.
How do you end up with a video game world that pulls you in?
How can you make it stand out from other games?
Your team will hit development walls and have to search for breakthroughs.
Here is the inside story of the making of Spyro the Dragon.
Oh my God!
Get his ass!
Yeah!
Ted!
The hardest part was coming up with what we were making.
The animation of a Tyrannosaurus Rex with wings and breathes fire.
You got the best of everything in the dragon.
Do you think he has a tattoo of it?
Do you think he had those Hawaiian dragon T-shirts?
Damn, this guy loves dragons.
This guy loves dragons.
Nasty!
Oh, we can hear Spyro talking.
Which one is this?
Is this Spyro 1?
Oh, the green screen.
Spyro 1.
Wow!
Alex, you don't have to do the interview.
Someone just get an Alex actor.
Flower case style.
I can't understand what he is saying.
This guy is just like, do I really have to be part of the interview?
Oh my God!
Somebody save Alex!
Wow, that guy is so awesome looking.
It's a sheep!
No way!
That's so sad!
Of all people who laugh so hard at someone being shy, it's because he is so... I feel bad for him.
That's why I'm laughing.
Look at 90's people.
I can't... I can't hear him.
They just were like, yeah that's the take.
Oh Alex, you are a freak.
Oh, I hate the flying levels.
What?
What did you say?
He got really excited about the flying levels.
I didn't like the flying levels.
I'm not very good at them.
Thanks for playing these classics from my childhood.
Of course!
Why is he saying it so sensual like that?
In every single place where you can dash, there is a secret place.
Oh it's the original Spyro.
That's right.
You guys said it wasn't Tom Kenny.
That's his name right?
Crash Bandicoot!
Taco Bell Chihuahua!
My credits are Crash Bandicoot and Taco Bell Chihuahua.
They look nice.
This is so awesome.
Starship Troopers?
Highlander?
Wow!
You used to try to speedrun this game?
Because I didn't have a memory card.
Oh my gosh!
Here I take your hard core.
Stop bullying the team?
No, I'm not bullying!
I love this!
Wait, that's Mr. Krabs!
What?
I forgot?
Oh God!
I forgot that he was Mr. Krabs.
Why didn't they credit that Mr. Krabs?
Early Fall.
Try the demo in the vault.
And then we have behind the scenes of Crash Bandicoot.
What is this?
Warped?
Crash Bandicoot Warped?
Yes.
Download station.
Research and development.
Code archive.
It's the vault!
This is where we get all the games.
Alright guys.
I didn't think it would just show up like that.
Spiral the Dragon.
A bug's life!
Also, there is something really cool on this.
The chat is kind of covering it.
But do you see that?
It's called imports.
There is just one.
But they have one single Japanese game on here which I think is kind of really neat.
Medieval 1?
Wow.
Tomb Raider 3?
Metal Gear Solid?
I don't know.
I never heard of that one before.
Cooler Borders 3.
Small Soldiers.
NFL Game Day 99.
NHL Face Off 99.
Rallycross 2.
Sounds dumb, don't play it.
We did the Spiral... It was Spiral 3, but we did Spiral in the last one.
I'm kind of really curious about a bug's life.
Actually, I want to try Iida Bull first.
The PlayStation though wasn't region locked.
It was?
The PS1 was?
Was the PS2 region locked?
It was?
Hold on, I'm going to do what was here.
Circle, square, circle, square.
In the ball?
Are you sure?
Oh, in the main menu.
How do I get out of here?
PS1 and PS2 were region locked.
I don't remember that at all.
Circle, square, circle, square.
It's not working.
Also, the next time you want to get my attention about something...
Don't send it in all caps, please.
Just looks like you're shouting at me.
One
guy, okay.
Gonna put you in time out.
That one military game looks cool, Small Soldiers.
I want to play, I want to try that one too.
Wait, import.
Start.
I can't see small letters without my glasses.
Wait, so they didn't translate any of it?
Yume janai?
Nihongo.
I don't even know what type of game this is.
I swear I'm not lying.
I'm telling you...
I'm telling you, it didn't work though.
Circle.
One player versus...
Oh, we can't do it.
We can only do one player.
I forgot.
Oh, it's JP control.
So now circle is...
X is modoru.
Plastic?
What is this game?
They're like, select your challenge.
I don't even know what these...
AI version?
I can't do that one.
Television version.
What?
Final?
Maybe we shouldn't do final.
Okay, let's just do special preview.
What is this?
The practice.
What am I doing?
I don't need a replay.
Thank you.
Oh gosh, there is a time limit.
Oh my god.
It's so sensitive.
My controller is so sensitive though.
It's just practice.
It's just a practice.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Okay.
It's so loud.
It scares me.
It is cool the way it like...
turns, right?
Do we get to...
try the other course?
Or does it kick us out?
Minto Ichiban.
Why did it send us...
Why did it send us all the way back to the very beginning?
Why did it do that?
I played this when I was a kid.
This is insane.
I thought it was all a dream.
Evan, what did you say?
What did you say?
Yo, we playing...
Actually...
Oh no, it didn't have Tony Hawk.
Or wait, maybe one of them does.
Hold on.
Why do every single one of these have Spyro on it?
Maybe I should have started this one.
Because maybe I should have gone in like...
order of gear, right?
Let's try that tiny soldier one.
Spyro is big.
I mean, I love Spyro.
Oh wait.
I wanna play A Bug's Life.
I wanna play it.
Oh my goodness.
Throw berries.
Pick up seeds.
Throw berries when they are being carried.
Change seed color.
When holding or hand standing on a seed.
Or you jump.
It's both changing the seed color and jumping.
R1, kick.
R1 plus square is kick.
Why can't square just be kick?
Oh wait, because square is throw the berries.
Well, what does circle do then?
Why can't circle be kick the enemies?
Okay, whatever.
I've never played this before.
Did you ever watch the Small Soldiers movie?
I don't think so.
TLDR.
Berries.
Oh wow.
Traveller's Tales.
How many of these companies are like gone now, you know?
More Disney.
Oh wait, are we gonna get a trailer for A Bug's Life 2?
Nope.
They hate us.
Level 1.
Welcome to Ant Island.
Find the entrance to the Ant Hill.
It's the whole level.
They make Lego games.
Okay, start.
Oh my gosh, I used to have a plushie of this character.
Am I killing that ant right there?
Is that a bad ant?
He looks kind of vicious.
Oh my god.
Oh wait, it's...
R1.
Oh damn!
We hate those ants.
Okay, how do I move the camera?
Wait, actually, how do I move the camera?
Excuse me, I can't turn around.
I can't turn around.
Oh my god.
He's trying to get me to turn, but I literally...
Oh there we go.
Okay, okay.
Oh god.
It's... I was using analog stick.
I'm an idiot.
Sorry guys.
Where's the entrance?
Oh god, this game is making me dizzy.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
Is this a seed?
Take the seed.
I got it!
Throw!
Oh my god!
This is an asshole.
I think I saw a cricket over here.
Aren't those the bad guys in the movie?
Oh my god.
Why is this so terrible?
This is so...
This is the worst game I've ever played in my entire afterlife!
Oh god!
She's following me.
What is this?
Is this water?
No, this game is good.
It is?
Okay.
Oh god.
Oh, it showed me where the entrance is, I think.
How do I not know how to go home?
Oh yes, there's a cricket.
Okay, I can throw berries at him.
Oh, this guy too.
Oh, kill him, kill him, kill him.
Give me a...
Okay!
Okay, we collect our name.
Oh my god, please.
Oh, there's a golden berry there.
Do you think I can jump?
Do you think I can reach it?
Everything's out to kill me!
I'm just an ant!
Good thing there's no fall damage.
This game is making me actually so sick.
Oh jeez.
Oh, I killed his ass before he could even touch me.
I'm gonna eat this...
What is this?
I don't know what that is.
This game is confusing!
Am I supposed to take the seeds or...?
Yeah, stay away from me.
You're ants that we hate.
We hate these ants.
These ants suck.
Oh wait, that's another number... number... letter.
Oh my god, why is the camera so bad?
Please.
Do you jump on the seed?
I don't know.
I can't jump on these.
Oh my god.
Okay, pick up this.
Walk over here before the guy comes back.
Wait, oh no.
What?
Oh, what the hell just happened?
This is so...
Yes!
We got it!
Oh my god.
Hardest boss of PS1 is the camera.
You know what?
Screw it.
I don't care about whatever the hell that is.
I'll go hungry before I deal with any of this shit.
I swear.
Suddenly a horror game for real.
Oh god.
Oh, it's horrible.
What
is that?
Every time I see it, it disappears.
I'm a dead ant.
I've been pesticide.
I'm actually gonna commit pesticide right now if I have to keep playing this game.
Don't let me inside my home!
Please!
Oh god.
I can't see anything.
This is the worst game ever.
Who said this was peak?
Oh!
We are so close to spelling!
This camera is so terrible.
What is this?
What the hell is that?
And where is the last...oh, hold on.
Okay, thanks for the berry.
I already saw that because I'm not blind.
Even my prepubescent mind could tell this game was horrible.
Are you guys enjoying this game?
Do you have fun becoming a little ant?
Are you feeling really immersed?
Are you feeling so immersed?
What the hell does this thing do?
Does it pick up that?
What is this thing?
And I can't attack while I'm in it.
Oh my god, he's coming for me.
Okay.
It's starting to lag.
The way the bugs explode is funny.
And what is this girl doing up here?
What is she doing?
What do I do with you?
What do you want from me?
I don't like it.
If you're trying to help me, you're not doing a very good job.
What the hell am I doing?
What is going on?
Oh, that's right.
I can change the seed color.
And then I hop on top of it and something else happens.
Oh my god.
It turned into...
What?
Oh, what?
Huh?
Oh, we did it.
Oh, we finally made it somewhere else.
This guy looks really freaked out.
Like, he looks like he's seen things.
And honestly, I have.
I don't want to be an ant anymore.
This sucks.
Being an ant is like... Oh my god.
Yeah, kill that guy.
Wait, where's the last letter of my name?
I'm never gonna beat this game.
I've never... You know what?
Let's just go inside.
And then I'll beat it.
Let's just... Chapter 1.
Let me in!
It was so worth it.
Oh, it hurts.
Wait, what happens when you finish the Metal Gear one, I wonder.
Oh gosh.
Sorry for one guying you, Minto.
Video proof is here.
Oh, code is square, circle, square, square, square.
But it might be copyright.
So play like 10 seconds...
You are so close.
So square, circle, square, square, square.
The same thing, but with Snake's face.
How did that get past quality control?
I'm surprised Disney approved of that.
Oh gosh, someone spent their whole afternoon making that screen.
So that 26 years later would become beat comedy on it.
It looks like a shit post for real.
Oh my god.
I want to see... I wasn't actually going to play the Metal Gear demo.
But I'm so curious.
I'm so curious.
What was I saying?
I'm so curious what the level complete looks like.
Did we get the full intro and everything?
I just bought this because I was like...
You are about to play a demonstration version of Metal Gear Solid.
The fuck did you do to the camera in Bugs Life?
It's not meant to look like that.
I didn't do anything!
Are we going to get the full intro?
A Hideo Kojima game.
No way.
Oh my gosh.
We actually get the intro?
That's crazy.
I kind of want to skip it because I want to get into the game, but I don't want to skip it at the same time.
I'm surprised it's in English.
I'm surprised it's in English actually.
What?
Holy shit!
No, that's not Solid Snake.
Oh my gosh.
The actual stage name.
Boom.
This is...Coming to this from Bugs Life is actual whiplash.
It's actually such like a...
I can't believe this demo disc has Metal Gear Solid and then a Bugs Life.
And Shaman.
Sean Baker is the name of the protagonist.
Oh my gosh!
Yes!
There's also some MGS1 demos in JP.
Oh, depending on which demos you got.
I knew there were some in Japanese.
One man infiltration mission baby!
OSP.
How far does the demo go I wonder.
Choo, choo, choo, choo, choo.
Choo, choo, choo, choo, choo, choo.
We should put it in...
Oh my god.
I'm just like imagining a kid...
Like...
Starting this up.
And it's just so amazing.
You know?
Oh, there's only no game.
There's nothing else on the menu.
Oh my gosh, Sean Baker!
He's got that dog in him.
Yeah.
Oh, Doug Stone is Doug Stone?
Steal it.
He'll be through me.
I know it.
I'm going to swat down a couple of bothersome flies.
I can't.
This is just so amazing.
And then you have a Bugs Life!
Bugs Life literally gave me motion sickness.
And then you have Liquid.
You have like the best game ever.
And then a Bugs Life on the same disc.
I want to cry.
Guys, I'm sorry.
I think I'm going to skip the codex.
Which I never would do.
Can I skip them?
Oh, yeah.
I want to get through it.
I want to see where the demo goes until.
Swim.
Oh no, don't expect any speedruns.
Someone is going to come in and be like, why the hell is she playing Metal Gear Solid?
Going to be like, why the hell is she playing Metal Gear Solid?
I can't with this girl.
Yeah!
I saw nothing.
Don't worry about it.
Oh god, he did see me!
Oh shit.
Don't kill me please.
Don't kill me!
I just want to play the demo!
You can play the bug's life!
There he is.
Oh, we're waiting.
We're waiting.
Come here.
Let me satchel my rations just in case.
Oh shit!
We're so fine everybody.
Oh shit.
There it is.
It's like, when is this going to calm down?
Just like old times.
Of course!
They didn't even notice that I killed a man.
Alright, get out of here mister.
Oh shit, don't see me.
I'm running.
When does this game come out?
Game of the year!
Sorry.
It doesn't slow down one bit.
It feels wrong.
I never skip cutscenes.
I never skip cutscenes in Metal Gear.
Mintos playing Metal Gear again!
But otherwise it's going to be so long.
I have so many games to get through.
I wonder, I can't tell when, how...
How...
How long of a demo this...
Like, where would be a good stopping point?
Maybe getting into the warehouse?
No, that feels too short, right?
When you get to the vents?
Yeah, that's what I was thinking.
I don't know.
Must be timed.
Do you think it's timed instead?
If we just ran around and be silly?
Whose footsteps are these?
The vents.
The demo ends after Meryl.
Meryl!
Oh my gosh, that feels so long.
Oh shit.
Nobodies.
Let's grab that.
No!
That guy is like coming right back!
I got my gun.
Anyway...
My heartbeat.
Oh no!
I can go back and get the ration.
I think I'm lazy.
I was never even here.
Oh gosh.
Please unequip.
Thank you.
Where
is the guy?
Where is the guy at?
Our sleepy guy.
What a demo.
Nice.
Wow.
He's on vacation.
Oh, because I set off the alarm.
He's doing his own thing.
He doesn't...wow.
He doesn't need me.
By the way, the demo has a full codec call.
This is craziness.
We are about to hear Master.
Master is coming in!
Follow the rat.
I can't believe Mint tricked me into watching her play Metal Gear again.
Master Miller!
Master.
McDonald's Miller.
Master McDonald's.
That guy's got some really sick glasses.
Guys, I'm just so curious.
What does the end of the demo look like?
This is different than the one I had.
Mine's had JP voices.
Ended as soon as you entered the vent.
Interesting.
Oh, so it's a mystery.
It's a mystery.
Where is the guy?
I hear him.
I love the ambiance here.
I wish I had a fork so I could eat these rats.
Wait, what if I call Mei Ling?
Because I can't save, right?
Oh wait, that's right.
I'm in here.
Oh wait!
You can save here in the commercial version.
That's so funny!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Buy the game everybody.
Buy the game.
Look for clues.
Wait, where is this guy?
Oh, there he is.
He's not going to save me, right?
Hello?
What?
Oh my god.
Stop, stop, stop.
Go away.
Do you think they'll hear me?
I wish I had a box.
Oh god.
Wait, this guy is coming up here.
No, we're fine.
The box upstairs.
Go away, mod.
Wait, so this is...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The green dot.
Wait, so it might end at the diaper chief.
Bye bye.
Action button.
Action button?
It looked like I couldn't go to B2.
Because it was like grayed out.
I didn't try though.
Let me go back and try.
Before we get to the diaper chief, because that might be the end of the demo.
Take me now.
Let's go see.
It's on purpose, right?
OK.
I thought so.
Oh my gosh.
I'm just imagining how awesome this game is.
And then you have a bug's life.
I can't get over it.
Ah, see?
Oh,
it does have the vent here.
I was going to say, wait, it was hard to tell...
if the vent was there or not.
It was hard to tell.
Somebody out there is like, bug's life is better than Metal Gear Solid.
Someone probably was like me and played a lot of a bug's life.
And barely touched Metal Gear.
I love this game so much!
I don't know if we'll need these or not, but...
Johnny sounds congested.
I caught a damn cold.
Johnny...
That guy is a looker, man.
We never knew how hot Johnny was.
Until so many years later.
Until like a decade later.
Sexy lady.
Not him.
Dude's a goddamn dreamboat.
I know, that's what I'm saying.
Did we get this whole cutscene?
Maybe it ends after Psycho Mantis?
Because we can't even go to B2, so...
It's me.
Your worst nightmare.
Are you going to buy Metal Gear Solid after playing this demo?
I don't know.
He looks like a Lego person.
I'm just not into it.
It's the full game.
The graphics just don't look good.
Like I just don't think I can get into it.
You know?
The first hot girl with IVs.
I feel like it will end after that scene where she gets into the elevator.
Yeah, probably, right?
OK, I'm going to skip it you guys.
I'm going to skip it.
Sorry.
Oh it hurts!
We are not here to play Metal Gear Solid though.
You knew?
Metal Gear is one of the most secret black projects.
We are not here to play Metal Gear.
Metal Gear!
Hi Rex!
Oh my gosh, so cute.
I was actually...oh my gosh.
Keep going, keep going.
Gosh, these cutscenes are crazy long.
Oh my gosh.
This is like...
The kid is probably just like...
This is like a whole movie.
This is crazy.
Metal Gear.
What is this?
Ed Wattser, thank you so much for the 10th gift and thank you!
I just said no.
Hold on, I'm trying to fix something on my computer.
Oh, IVS!
Oh no, IVS!
Woah!
So...sorry, I should have let it play out.
So he dies and then that's the ending?
No way!
Oh my gosh, he dies and that's such a cliffhanger.
That's a good place.
That's a...actually I think that's a better place to end it than...
I think that's a better place to end it than at the elevator.
Wow!
Oh my gosh, I would have been so...
I mean, I am foaming at the mouth, but...
Oh my gosh!
That would have been crazy!
I'm kind of disappointed though that we didn't get Snake's face plastered all over the screen.
It's kind of sad.
How do I get out of here?
Option?
No?
Weak.
Strong.
I played this demo disc with my dad.
He would just endlessly try and run away from the guards.
He thought it was hilarious that cigarettes drained your health.
We both liked it more than Bugs Life.
How do I get out of here?
Do I have to...oh.
Wait.
Uh-oh.
I think I can get out from here.
I'm trapped!
I'm trapped in a Metal Gear loop!
Start and select at the same time.
OK, thank you.
I thought it was like select because the other games were just select, but then I was like wait a second, that's the codec!
Metal Gear?
Metal Metal Gear Gear?
OK, so what was that cheat?
It was...circle...
Square, circle, square, square, square?
Square, circle, square, square, square.
It didn't work.
Hold on, let me see if I can find the super chat.
No.
No, it's not showing me the super chats.
On the demo menu.
Oh, the demo menu.
Wait, Agent, you're the one who knows!
You're the one who one-guide me!
What was it?
Square, circle, square, square, square?
Wait.
Square, circle, square, square, square.
I'm good to use.
Liquidoki loves bug life.
Yeah, she would.
I don't know.
Why don't we figure that out?
What else should we?
Oh, small soldiers!
I wanna try this one.
Weapon select.
Strife.
Select special weapon.
Deploy.
Use special weapon.
Allies.
Jump.
Fire.
Move.
Directional aim weapon.
Oh my goodness.
Let's try this.
I swear to god it was in that video I linked.
I can't open videos while I'm streaming!
Okay, please don't.
Okay, I might actually time you out because...
Because... You can't just send me a link.
That's not how this...
My entire monitor is the PlayStation.
My goodness.
It's a Dreamworks game?
Small soldiers.
Oh my gosh.
My other... Oh my god.
My other...
Small soldiers anecdote is that my local theater had 15 foot statues of the two main characters.
Doesn't that defeat the purpose?
Aren't they supposed to be small soldiers?
Why are they 15 feet?
Oh my god.
Why does it... Pargon.
Pargon.
It looks like... It looks like Pargon!
Semi-dark movie.
What?
Oh, there is a password.
This is not what I expected.
I expected more...
Just military.
Antorok.
Pargon.
Mantorok.
Red Gormor.
Pargon.
Let's try one player.
It's just me, myself and I.
This is literally the MGS's Toy Story.
What?
The commandos are mining Gorgon-ty ore.
The creepy caverns obliterate their infernal mining machine.
Neutralize turrets and flying sentry horde.
Whoop chip for access card to lower force fields.
Use slam fist to smash all marauders.
Oh, thank you.
I like how... Square is fire.
Select special ally.
Deploy special ally.
Jump.
Sniper mode?
Why does this feel like Eternal Darkness?
Oh,
I'm strapped.
Wait, what the hell?
I am so small.
I'm a small soldier.
Do I have ammo?
I guess not.
Oh god!
Oh my god!
Strafe!
Is he following me?
Yes.
Strafe is the way.
I'm terrified of this game right now.
I'm actually scared of this game right now.
Am I OK?
I'm like meowing.
Are these bad guys?
I can also do that!
Avenge me comrade.
Oh my god, he exploded.
Wait, no!
My special...
Avenge me comrade.
This is insanity.
What's over there?
Do you think I can make it there?
Oh, this is the sniping one, right?
This is spooky.
This is scary.
The ambiance is going hard.
I know, right?
Goodness gra...
I don't want to be a small soldier anymore.
I want to be a large soldier.
I don't like this.
And it said I can move with the analog stick, but I cannot.
I can only move with the D-pad.
It totally pointed to the analog stick though.
OK.
Strafe, strafe.
OK, hold on.
I'm going to bring out my army.
Deploy army.
Nevermind, that didn't do anything.
Oh, the analog is not on.
You're right.
Oh, there we go.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
He's moving on his own!
What's happening?
This was a bad idea.
I think I'm going to die here.
Oh, the framerate.
Everything is happening.
Oh god.
There are so many things.
Why can't I aim?
Why can't it be like Doom?
Why can't you auto-aim?
You idiot.
Oh my god, that guy is coming at me.
No, no, no.
Don't come here.
I'll get him first.
I'll kick his ass first.
OK,
we're killing him.
We're killing him.
I'm strafing.
I'm playing the game.
I don't know where the tur...
Avenge me, my comrades.
Oh my god.
Oh, this is secret.
I heard the code to unlock the secret video is actually...
What is shooting?
If... OK, to give you an idea...
OK, I think what's confusing me about it is I'm trying to control the camera.
But like the camera... So you control the camera and then you...
But sometimes I can't... I'm pressing forward.
I'm not moving forward, but I'm controlling the camera.
But... So, I think maybe...
Sometimes I turn...
And then I have to turn and move and then turn and move forward and then turn and move forward and then turn and move forward.
That's how you have to play... That's how you have to move.
Which is what makes it so... You can't... I guess unless you're running like this, but it's still just...
Oh my god.
Yeah, that's how I remember this game was.
What is shooting?
What's here?
Oh, just kidding.
Jump.
Oh, nevermind.
OK, nevermind.
This area sucks.
Can I jump here?
Oh god!
Oh my god!
I ran away!
Tactical retreat?
What the hell is this game?
How am I supposed to defeat that?
That's a whole ass turret!
OK, hold on.
Oh my god.
Am I wasting this?
I think I am.
There we go.
Nice.
Why is everything barking in this game?
OK, we have the red key.
I see there is something up there.
I don't know what it is though.
Shit!
You're still alive!
Nice.
Oh my gosh, we killed it.
But then there is also this guy over here too.
Oh my god!
There is two of them!
Run away!
OK, hold on.
OG aim assist.
Oh gosh.
I don't think there is aim assist.
I don't think there is really aim assist here.
Oh god.
I have to like turn?
Oh my god.
OK, run.
Oh goodness.
Oh no.
Oh god!
I can't...
We are fighting for duty.
I don't like this zone!
I hate you!
We both died at the same time.
Avenge me comrades.
Where am I?
Did I kill him?
No way.
Where is he?
Where is the thing he dropped?
Avenge me comrades.
This is one of those games you really want to cheat code for.
Absolutely.
Oh my god.
Please.
Aim.
We are doing it!
We are being a tiny soldier!
I don't like being a tiny soldier.
I want to be a big soldier now.
This is me being a tiny soldier.
What are these?
I want to watch the movie now just so I understand what the hell is going on.
At least the enemies stay defeated.
Otherwise it would be absolute torture.
It would be so difficult.
OK.
Here we go.
I hear him.
Can whatever is shooting... Please.
Please.
Just... Can you aim for it?
Whatever you are aiming for just aim.
I'm trying to run.
Oh my god.
There is three of them.
Yeah!
Help me out buddy!
Oh I think he is down.
Avenge me comrade!
I can't move and fight at the same time.
Go after him.
You know what?
Go get him for me.
Thank you.
What the hell was that?
Was that my buddy?
Where did he go?
Buddy?
Is that my... Is that my buddy?
Oh that's my buddy.
Hey buddy.
Where are you going?
Come on.
Let's keep going.
I'm going to die buddy.
I ain't going to make it buddy.
Oh I got it.
For some reason jumping didn't want to grab it.
But that's OK.
I don't know what that did.
Maybe it's like capture the flag.
This is a different version of the same disc I have.
Sorry for the one guy saga and yelling.
I was getting upset at myself.
It's OK.
I know you were trying.
I know you just wanted to share something with me.
It's all good.
I forgive you.
Where do I go from here?
Do I jump actually here?
But like...
Buddy, but... No!
Don't prepare for duty.
Oh I can jump these.
OK, just kidding.
No, my buddy can't though.
My buddy can't jump these.
Buddy!
Is my buddy here?
I don't think so.
I don't think buddy is here guys.
Rep buddy.
Oh my god.
Hey, let me up here first please.
Thank you.
Let me at least get... Oh my god.
Please turn.
Turn the camera.
Run.
Do something.
Aim.
Just run.
Shoot.
Do anything.
Oh my god.
Special!
Oh good.
I got that guy.
Yeah, yeah.
Aim.
Nice, nice, nice.
I think I'm...I think
I'm...I'm trying.
I'm trying.
There is health.
This game sucks.
This game is so hard.
Why is it like...
My buddy!
Alright, take care of him.
Hey buddy, you are supposed to actually...
Avenge me comrades.
Yeah!
How long is this demo?
There goes my buddy.
Buddy no!
You can't get him!
Don't be a hero!
Retreat!
Retreat buddy!
Who are you attacking?
Oh god.
He is seeing phantoms.
Buddy, you can't get them.
They are across the way buddy.
We just gotta run for it.
Run!
Don't stop!
Oh shit.
Buddy!
Buddy, I need your help buddy.
Buddy, buddy, get in here buddy.
Buddy, buddy, buddy.
Buddy, buddy.
Buddy, buddy, where are you buddy?
Buddy.
Buddy, I need you.
OK, these are supposed to be homing, right?
Buddy, what are you doing?
Where are you?
Buddy, this is the real battles here!
Oh god, I'm gonna die.
Oh, nevermind.
I fell to the ground and I'm lost.
Where am I?
He is fighting his own demons.
You think he is still alive?
Guys, I don't think he is still alive.
What the hell did I just throw?
I think...I think I just threw a grenade and I didn't mean to.
Turn around!
I'm done!
I'm done with this one!
Little soldiers.
Oh god, they are too little.
They don't have...they need to get bigger.
They need to eat their greens.
Oh my god.
Oh, small soldiers.
My bad.
Guys, I think I'm good with this one.
I think I'm good with this...
thing.
Hold on, give me one second.
Actually...
I have to switch my monitor real quick.
Watching small soldiers as a kid traumatized me about getting stuck in a sink garbage disposal.
I guess I can do Tomb Raider for a minute.
A little bit.
I don't need controls.
I just want to get to the last two discs and make sure we have enough time for those two.
Sorry, I spent a lot of time on that one.
Yup, Tomb Raider 3!
Ok, oh.
Why am I so stiff?
Hello?
Ma'am, turn around.
I can't do this again.
It's tiny soldiers all over again you guys.
I can't do this.
Oopsie.
Maybe I should have looked at the controls.
I can't do this.
I was pressing every button.
That was roll.
What is action?
Ok, I was jumping.
Draw weapon.
I don't think I had any weapons.
Ok, revengeance, revengeance, revengeance.
My stomach hurts.
It just threw me into the game.
She was just like, oh wait.
Ok, oh, we have to do that.
Oh god, the controls in this are really bad.
Can I analog?
Ok, I can.
But like, oh my god.
How did we do this?
You guys...
90's gamers are... I can't even move properly.
You guys, I just keep sidestepping.
90's gamers are the strongest warriors, I swear to god.
This is impossible.
How do I move?
Stop please.
Ok, I...
Use the D-pad.
Oh my god.
I think I just need to run.
Get up.
No, please.
Lara Croft.
Let's just admire how sexy she is.
She's got a really big forehead though.
Ok, Lara.
Here we go.
I'm just gonna run for it.
Alright, leave!
I can't see anything.
Oh my god.
Lara, run!
Not that way.
That way.
Lara, run.
Get out of here!
Oh my god, don't stop!
I can't see.
Oh yeah!
Give me those.
Lara Croft, please.
Take the weapons.
I pressed X!
I pressed...
X.
X!
Oh, I got him.
How do I fire?
I think I also X.
I'm fighting for my afterlife in here, you guys.
Never stood a chance.
Oh my god, the controls.
The controls.
How do we have Metal Gear Solid and then whatever the hell... Oh, the wrong way.
Then whatever the hell these games have been.
I swear to god.
I swear!
Maybe that red button?
Oh god.
Here?
Oh, sorry.
Put my guns away.
My guns are still out though.
Maybe here.
Ok.
Oh my god.
I played Tomb Raider.
Before.
Well...
Because my dad liked Tomb Raider.
Ok, not that.
Someone actually saying MGS1 has good controls.
Comparatively speaking...
Yeah.
Comparatively speaking, Metal Gear has amazing controls compared to every game we've played today.
Roblox.
Roblox oof.
Oh.
It just locks.
I think...
I think this is the end of the demo.
What the hell am I supposed to do?
Maybe we go back.
Got my guns out.
Hello?
Who's coming for me?
You're gonna meet Ebony and Ivory.
One single guy works at this place?
Do I do anything with him?
Hey buddy.
Hey, you got something for me?
People really understand how much Mario 64 did for controls in 3D games.
They're out of budget.
T-bag him?
Oh yeah.
Button on the wall?
I tried pressing it.
This one right here, right?
OK, thank you.
That's annoying.
Action button, right?
Maybe...
Maybe...let me try square.
You have to be precise.
How...how much more...
I can only get so close to it.
Hold L1.
Or R2.
Nope, those are not the controls.
L1 is looking around.
Press the button, Lord!
Oh, thank god.
Yes.
I love a...oh, OK.
How do I duck now?
Oh my goodness.
I thought I could roll into it.
Please.
R2?
Oh, thank you.
OK.
Oh my god, maybe this is Metal Gear Solid.
Look how hot she is.
I can't see anything.
Please.
Grab onto the ledge, Lara Croft!
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
You can't...oof, that's my line.
OK.
We got that.
Stop backing...jumping back, please!
Even the way she climbs is sexy.
Maybe that's why they want you to do it so many times.
Really get your money's worth, I guess.
What is that?
No, no, stop.
I'm just trying to turn.
Oh no, if I press back...OK.
No, no.
Back.
OK, now you can back.
Back it up, baby.
There we go.
OK, more health.
Oh gosh, why am I even grabbing all this stuff?
What's the point?
This is so...
I have to be so delicate.
OK girl, yeah.
That's right.
What is this thing anyway?
Do I have an inventory?
Oh, no.
Pause.
OK.
Please, run, turn.
I have to do that like run and turn thing.
This is why I never played Tomb Raider.
I don't blame you.
Why is it so quiet?
Oh my god.
Run Lara Croft, run!
We're not gonna make it.
Oh, nevermind.
Ouch.
Back!
Good job everybody.
Why is it so quiet?
That was a ladder?
The first dodge was very cool.
Thank you.
Gosh, these games are making me tired.
Let's do the next disc now.
Are we good to go?
This one just frustrated me.
We didn't need Rage Games back in the day.
Next one is... Let's go with... What's the date on this?
This one is 2003.
This one I have no idea what's on it.
We shall see.
We shall see what is on it.
Then the last one we have is the Holiday 2004.
This one is... Now we're into the PlayStation 2 discs.
So yeah, we're full on PS2 era baby.
The memories, right?
I need some more water after this though.
The video game demos contained on this DVD are early versions that have not completed the SCEA testing cycle.
EA Games, challenge everything.
What the...
What is this?
Oh, 007!
This
is the guy that was grabbing the Indiana Jones stuff earlier.
In his little tux.
Bond.
James Bond.
I
have no idea what's gonna be on this disc.
This is from... Oh, I should have looked at it.
It's from the PlayStation Magazine issue 76.
Wow, sexy lady.
Why is it... His eyes are so freaky though.
Best Bond game ever.
Don't a lot of people like the one from the Nintendo though?
I never had a 64 so I don't know.
Is that Dragon Ball?
Wait.
Ape Escape 2!
And Dragon Ball Z Budokai!
No way, Ape Escape.
Oh my gosh!
Wait, we have to try the Ape Escape!
Wait, download.
100% complete.
All items in travel station except...
Is this a demo or is it...
I can't tell.
I think these are saves.
No!
I don't think these are actual games.
That's so sad.
The 2 that I actually wanna do.
Let's see what we have.
We have Sokong 2.
We have Rise of Honor.
Oh sorry, Rise 2 Honor.
Oh my gosh, Desert Storm 2!
Disney's Extreme Skate Adventure.
ESPN College Hoops.
Freedom Fighters.
Jimmy Neutron!
Madden 2004.
NCAA Football 2004.
R-Type Finals?
And Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles.
Oh sorry, Whiplash.
007.
Oh wow, there's actually so much.
TMNT?
Let's do TMNT.
I don't need controls.
Oh my gosh, what if they say Cowabunga you guys?
What if they say Cowabunga?
I don't need controls.
Konami?
It's a Konami game?
Yeah!
Oh I get to choose.
I can be...
Donatello!
Michelangelo!
Leonardo!
Raphael!
Donatello...
Who should I be?
Mikey?
Oh, I can only be Leonardo.
Just kidding.
I can only be Leonardo.
Are you sure?
You give me no other choice.
Don't give me the illusion of choice.
Turtles, count it off.
Turtles!
Area 2.
Wow, they're just throwing us in, huh?
Pizza shop.
Ah!
Is this Metal Gear Rising?
Yeah,
I'm a heavy turtle.
I can't jump very high.
Come here, guys!
Slice
and dice!
Oh my god!
Slice and dice!
I'm killing it, you guys.
Oh shoot, nevermind.
They're killing me.
I dodged that though.
Oh shoot.
Run away!
How do I...
Hey, come back here.
Come back here, buddy.
I'm going, I'm going.
Oh my god.
Oh, nevermind.
Nevermind.
Slice and dice!
Oh my god!
I'm amazing!
That was the...
Don't look at that.
Don't avoid me!
Don't dodge me!
Go!
Is there like no items or anything?
I just keep running and...
I keep running and...
What the hell are these?
Oh gosh, there's a real person.
I think there's a real big difference between killing humans and then killing little robot bunnies.
You know what I'm saying?
It's kind of crazy.
Stay down!
Slice and dice!
That is like the arcade style where you can't go any further.
You just like defeat all the enemies in a screen and...
Oh my god.
One for you!
Slice and dice!
Slice...
They're like little dinosaurs.
Slice and dice!
Guys, I think he likes slicing and dicing.
I have an inkling.
Sushi!
Stay down.
I think he likes slicing and dicing.
Something is giving me...
Did that beat it?
Hey, hey.
Chill out, guys.
Oh, I'm out of... Oh, I'm out of the shuriken.
Slice and dice!
What the hell was that?
Yeah, we had some sort of...
Oh nice, more.
What the hell?
Oh my god, they're all exploding so much.
I'm just mashing buttons, you guys.
I'm just... I'm becoming one with the turtle, you know?
One with the slicing.
I'm slicing, I'm dicing.
I don't feel like I...
This is my purpose.
It's to slice and dice.
I think that's how you play the game.
True.
He just whacks me on the head.
It's starting to get me good, though.
How do I reload my shuriken, I wonder?
What's this?
Oh, it's a fence-off.
What the...
Goodbye!
I think it's temporary.
That's kind of sad.
No!
My temporary defense...
Hello?
Pizza!
Not a single cowabunga.
Guys, this game might be the worst of all time.
This game might be terrible.
How am I getting hurt so badly?
They're hitting literally my shell.
Do you get a cowabunga at the end?
Okay, I'm trusting you guys.
I'm trusting you guys.
Oh, shoot.
They got me good.
Stop getting me!
Stop hitting my head!
Okay, I hear you.
I hear you.
I'm going.
I'm going!
Oh my god.
He just came in swinging.
That's my job!
Guys, I don't even know how to... How am I supposed to commentate on this?
She's playing the classic space slash, slice and dice combo.
Only real TMNT people are doing that combo.
Truly, it's a master.
She's a master of the craft.
She's slicing.
She's dicing.
Everything is exploding.
All she wants is a piece of pizza.
Slice and dice.
We're going!
How long is this demo?
Slice and dice.
Slice... Slice and dice.
I'm gonna kill this guy first.
I'm focusing on you.
You are my... Oh.
There we go.
I think it's Sony.
Oh my god, so cute!
Oh, did I just slip?
I'm sorry for her.
Did I slip on the water?
Get up!
Yeah, the car explodes.
The barrels explode.
Nice.
I don't remember which one was the strong attack.
If X was the strong attack and...
Square is my weak attack.
I can't remember.
Hey, I'm supposed to have a stronger attack, right?
Nice.
He says a full heal?
Damn.
It's ok, we don't need control.
So true!
I got more shooting gun, but it says that I have zero, so I don't know what's going on.
Oh, I'm at the limit of the...
Slice and dice.
I'm just like him.
Oh, damn.
Goodbye.
Slice and dice.
Bonus.
Max combo 14?
Ok.
Alright.
New record?
They didn't say it.
Oh.
Tell everyone that you know more than they do.
I can't believe there is no Cowabunga.
Guys, I'm not really feeling any of these other games.
I don't know.
Maybe Disney Skate.
Yeah, I'll try it for a second.
Wacky Proto Cooking Mama.
Oh, that sounds fun.
I still have one more disc, by the way, so don't worry.
I know what you did.
I don't need the controllers.
Ten real kids?
Wait, this might be copyrighted, so hold on.
I'm just gonna turn that down.
These kids.
Oh my gosh.
I didn't know that... What?
Except I didn't skateboard.
I did inline skating.
So I wouldn't have been chosen.
That's so messed up.
I'm gonna keep turning it down.
Oh, they're liking that kid.
Oh, nevermind.
How embarrassing.
You just completely...
The kid on the... Your tiny crotch, please.
Oh my god!
Is that the kids?
Wow!
They're playing the game.
They're like, that's me, dad.
I'm in the game.
Wasted.
I'm a Disney kid.
Wait, I thought it was... The picture showed Buzz Lightyear.
Oh, there he is.
I was like, I thought I was playing as...
As actual...
What the hell?
What are these?
Am I gonna play the game or is it just a trailer?
I can't get over the Buzz Lightyear.
What is going on?
Oh wow.
Disney Extreme Skate.
Oh, I think...
Before mods we had this game.
Okay, we can be Ryan.
We can be Ryan.
We can be Mally.
Simba.
Who gets no... Oh, not available in demo.
Okay, that's so sad.
Wait, no, Mickey!
They won't even let us choose him.
It doesn't even say not available in demo.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, we can be Woody.
I wanna be Buzz.
Yes!
We can be Zurg.
That's kind of awesome.
Tantor.
Okay, I don't want to be the real people.
That sucks.
Let's be Buzz.
And be Zurg.
Oh my god.
He's coming for us, you guys.
Oh, Angry Man.
Oh, Army Man.
Skate.
Okay, one, two...
Oh, is this copyright?
I don't know.
Oh my gosh.
It's okay, Buzz.
You got this.
Yeah, baby.
Oh, we're fine.
Yeah, we got this, guys.
We got this.
Oh gosh, he's really like limpy.
He's just flopping all over the place, this guy.
Yeah, baby.
Maybe I should've... Oh, we did a trick just then?
I don't know what the hell we just did, but...
What is this?
Oh, nice.
Not today, Zurg.
How do I stop it though?
Oh, nice.
Oh,
there's another person over here.
What did you guys say to me?
Now?
Oh, okay.
This way?
Oh, this way, this way.
Oh.
Sorry, I'm on a different journey now?
What?
Stop me, I'm Buzz Lightyear.
Wow.
The way Buzz moves is hilarious.
It really is so funny.
I'm not an army man.
I'm busy.
I'm collecting the letters to spell skate, okay?
Leave me out of this.
Leave me out of here.
Okay, hold on.
Let's get on here.
No, no, no.
How do I get in there?
We're gonna go up here.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
We get the soap.
Nice.
I don't know how we're skating upwards, but this is really impressive.
There's a penguin!
I lost my squeaker.
Could you help me find it?
Is that it?
At the very top?
Is that what you're trying to imply?
Nah.
Sorry, guy.
I can't help you.
I'm skating.
I'm going on my own pathway.
Oh gosh.
Buzz, I'm getting dizzy.
Buzz, where does this lead?
That was really anticlimactic.
And then... Shut up.
I don't want to get copyright.
With old Disney music.
You gotta shred.
Yeah, we gotta shred.
Where's the rest of the letters?
Oh, we made that!
Oh god!
Oh god.
This music is dangerous.
Maybe I should leave.
Oh no!
I think I should leave the game.
Where's your head at?
Yeah, this is copyright for sure.
I think...
I think I've had enough.
Get me out of here.
Exit demo.
My stream is gonna get taken down by the mouse, you guys.
What?
Did you know yesterday was exactly the 20 year anniversary of Snake Eater's release?
I did know that.
That's why yesterday in my karaoke I sang Snake Eater.
Play your favorite movie's wireless DVD remote controller.
For the PS2.
OK.
I'm not really feeling anything else in this one.
I think I'm gonna...
Go to the last disc.
Which has something I do really wanna play.
And I have actually something that I need to do in about...
In about an hour.
I can't go over.
So...
Let's do the last...
Let's do the last disc.
There's one thing on here I really do wanna do.
We can try some other things on here as well.
But not Beautiful Joe 2.
Because I don't want my save to be...
Alright.
Alright!
I think we have a better game on this one.
Oh, my... I just realized my...
My memory card isn't even plugged in.
I just noticed.
I was not even in.
I guess we could do it.
I'm so excited for the intros.
Oh, there was one.
Why would you do this to me?
Oh,
my gosh.
I was like...
I love the intros to these.
So funny.
OK.
We have Jack 3.
We have Ratchet and Clank.
We have Spyro, A Hero's Tale.
There it is.
Beautiful Joe 2.
We have the Incredibles!
We have Tuck 2.
Oh, my gosh.
I completely forgot this was a game.
We have Crash Twinsanity.
We have Escamapa!
I had this disc in my saves.
Tuck 2.
Oh.
No!
We have Star Wars Battlefront.
ATB Offroad Fury 3.
That's it.
I've never played Jak and Daxter.
What do you mean?
These are the menu controls.
Select menu item on previous screen.
What?
Better selection than the last disc.
I agree.
The last disc...
Like I said...
It doesn't have the games listed on it.
And I also don't have the...
Like anything that...
Like a case or anything for it.
So I had no idea what was on it.
I'm waiting for this moment.
I don't remember the PS1 sound.
What did the PS1 sound like?
What is this?
Is this spoilers?
Life?
This freak?
Holy boobs!
Yeah!
I don't know Aaron.
Jak?
Holy moly!
I promise.
They are talking so fast.
Who is the monkey?
I know Daxter.
He doesn't have a beak.
He's a monkey.
Oh no.
He's going to die.
I don't know what's going on.
Oh!
I'm getting spoiled completely.
Wasn't... Didn't he like have a glow up?
Like he was...
Like Jak was like really young and then in the second game he turned old.
Everyone got a glow up.
Oh no!
Ah man.
Oh no.
Oh god.
His ears are so long!
They are so long!
Chicken.
Family guy death pose.
Oh my god.
Oh we hate those guys.
The metal heads.
Jiggle.
Where are you guys looking?
Stop it!
Is there only three games in this?
Jak 1, 2, 3.
4 if you include the racer.
Ah there are some spin offs.
A racing game.
A Daxter game.
He's second dead.
No!
He's dead!
He's dead.
Everything is happening so fast.
He didn't even give him a chance to answer.
Then he's like I smell a storm.
Well the storm is already here.
Wow it's beautiful.
Everything is happening so fast.
Oh demo missions.
Watch intro movie.
Destroy metal head beasts.
Explore Ecomind.
Escort...ok no escort mission please.
Let's destroy some metal heads.
Exit vehicle.
Oh no.
Wait I have to drive.
Wait.
I can't...go back.
Wait, wait, wait.
I thought I was going to use my hands.
Oh no!
Go back!
No!
He's got such big teeth.
A wasteland metal head?
Oh I think we are in trouble.
Oh I can just be me.
Ok, let's go kick some butt!
Let's go kick some butt!
Over this way.
Do I have to take the car?
You'll need the car?
Oh I think I need the car to...
Then we can go around.
Ok this way.
It's only four of them guys.
We got this.
Alright.
Jump.
Double jump.
It will be a long walk.
What's in this way?
We can explore the whole world as a rooster.
Uh oh.
Did the door shut on me?
Oh wait a second.
Ok, phew.
We are fine.
Everything is fine.
Oh there is our car I think.
Let's get the most power.
Let's pick God's chosen car.
Oh God.
Ok guys, this is fine probably.
This is probably ok.
Ok this is the brakes.
Then press R1 to fire.
Ok, ok.
It's giving us a little tutorial while we go.
I see one.
It does not drift?
Mad mint.
Maybe not.
Nevermind.
Turn around.
You can drift if you press L1.
Let's see.
Oh kind of.
It does give you a little bit of a hoop.
Is that guy going to attack me or what are you doing man?
The next one.
There is two over here.
I don't know if we want to... Oh did he leave?
Did he leave?
Oh I hear him.
Right behind me.
He is coming after me.
Maybe...
Oh he is trying to destroy me.
Let's avoid that.
Where the hell does this guy keep going to?
You know what?
Let's leave this guy for now.
Oh there we go.
I could just shoot at them.
I'm not hitting any shot.
Where does he go to?
Over here.
Guys, we are gaming.
Freaky road.
Freaky, freaky.
So if I get out of the car...
Oh my god.
I'm on his ass.
We are fine.
I don't know where he... Oh there he is.
Oh shit.
I still have two left.
We got this.
Ok this isn't as bad as... Oh sorry.
I was going to say...
This isn't as bad of a driving as I thought it would be.
But we are fine.
Everything is fine everybody.
What the hell?
I sometimes think I have controller drift.
Oh my gosh.
I don't know where I am.
Turn around.
Ok.
Is that the sun over there?
It's so purple.
Avoid the tree?
Ok hold on.
Where is this guy?
There he is!
I think we are fine.
Honestly.
I think this guy... I think we don't even... I think this guy does not stand a chance against us.
Just saying.
I wish there was a reverse button.
Is this reverse?
Maybe this is reverse.
This is reverse.
Ok, ok, ok.
This way?
Just one more.
Where is this guy?
All the way...
Oh my gosh.
You guys weren't kidding.
This would have been the longest hike ever.
1 HP?
No, we have more than 1 HP.
Back it up.
I wish I could turn the camera.
There we go.
Alright.
What's that green thing on the map?
We are fine.
Everything is good.
See?
Turn that around.
What's that green thing on the map?
Yeah, I did a flip.
Ok, here it comes.
Yeah!
We took him down!
Oh, nevermind.
I thought we did.
Just kidding.
We almost took him down.
What the hell man!
You are dead!
For real this time.
Maybe?
Did we?
I didn't even hit him.
That's what we got.
I like the sound of your voice.
Spoilers?
I do not perceive.
Who is that?
Wow.
This is so long.
Just kidding.
That was the Jack 3.
How do I get out of here?
Let me out please.
Let me go back to the main menu.
Select start doesn't work.
It just takes me to this menu.
Takes me to the demo missions.
Select start doesn't work.
I might have to actually restart the whole... Oh my god.
I'm going to restart the whole console.
I guess we will hard reset.
That's so stinky.
L1.
Oh, well I already did it.
All shoulder buttons plus select start.
It almost didn't read it for a second.
I have limited time so I want to do Ace Combat.
I have a limited time.
It's also been like 4 hours of just demos.
Ace Combat baby!
I also wanted to do the Incredibles.
But that's OK.
Oh my
gosh.
No, I was just reading.
It's just... I'm starting with Ace Combat 5 so...
It's...
It's time.
Oh gosh.
It's a little complicated.
It's OK.
The song of the bird echoed in words.
Number 5.
This looks so good.
A war tears two nations apart.
A war fueled by courage.
By hatred.
Oh, not by courage.
Ah!
These people may well be the story I was looking for all this time.
In fact, I was sure of it.
So awesome!
Oh gosh.
Sorry, I'm just in advance.
I'm going to be so bad with the controls.
But it's been a long time since I played Ace Combat 7 so...
I'm on my hands and knees.
You must play this.
Of course!
I have... I own the whole Ace Combat series, you guys.
I've prepared for this moment.
Or rather, I am prepared for Ace Combat.
I own the entire series.
I know you do.
Yeah!
It's a whole lot of singing for an unsung war.
You have zero?
Yes.
You already got Ace Combat's skill.
It's called Crashing Blitz.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's just go for it.
Let's go for the...
F14.
Confirmed!
This one.
Yeah, that one.
Oh!
I get to choose each person.
I didn't realize.
Okay, we'll do...
Chopper.
Roger.
We'll do 2-2.
Confirmed.
Let me turn it down some.
Oh gosh.
These look so much more manageable.
Wow, I can't believe you get to control your wingman.
That's so fun.
Oh my gosh.
I see them.
Oh gosh.
How do I shoot my missile?
Oh god.
Oh god!
Miss!
How do I...
Okay, I'm yawing.
Oh god.
Miss!
Why am I missing?
Come on!
Miss!
Oh my gosh.
Get closer.
The controls.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
The controls.
I'm just gonna...
I hit!
There we go.
Hit!
And one more!
Yeah!
Where's that other guy go?
There's my teams over there.
Sharp down.
Where is it?
There it is.
I'm already so excited.
I can't wait to play.
I wonder if I can...
How do I lock on?
There we go.
Hit!
And...
Destroyed, baby!
How do I, like... How do I go faster and stuff?
I feel like the controls are very automated.
Free select?
Wait, I think this was...
Oh, there's like so many things.
Okay, hold on.
Alright, we're going in.
Oh, my thing is... My YouTube chat is broken, so if you're trying to tell me stuff, I cannot see!
My YouTube chat is broken again, guys.
Sorry.
Come on.
Actually, let's go change to this guy.
Can I?
There we go.
I think he's closer.
I'm just shaking all over the place.
Oh God.
Warning?
It didn't hit me.
I'm yawning!
Hit!
Hit, baby!
Oh, whoops.
Take him down!
Hit!
Where's the other guy?
Where did the other guy go?
Destroyed, baby!
Over here?
Wait, is that my...Where is he?
I can't tell what they look like on the...
Third person who?
I can't.
It won't let me switch to it.
I'm trying.
It won't let me switch to third person.
So I don't know.
Where did they go?
Oh gosh, they were right on me.
I had a feeling that was going to happen.
Hold on, I'm refreshing my YouTube chat.
One second.
We did a flip, guys!
We did a flip!
Yeah, I didn't hear any lady being like, pull up, pull up.
What the heck?
Guys, did you know I'm only 15k away from my goal of the year?
300,000 subscribers.
If you want more Ace Combat combat, consider subscribing and maybe tell your friends.
Sorry,
I just got reminded because I have to go to the back end to refresh my chat.
Did it go away?
I will personally find 15,000 people just to watch you play Ace Combat.
Wait, but I want to keep playing!
Where did you learn to fly?
What was it?
The shoulder buttons and then...
Humph!
John Ace Combat...
No!
This CD is super duper scratched up, so...
Well guys, I just have to play.
I think...
I get so indecisive because after...
So basically, I'm doing Devil May Cry right now and I'm doing some Metal Gear games and then I'll finish Metal Gear.
And I'm thinking, I can't decide after Metal Gear if I do Ace Combat or if I do Yakuza.
Both of them are quite long, so I'm like...
I don't know!
I
don't know which one to do.
Ace Combat is way shorter?
It's shorter actually.
What about Xenoblade?
Xenoblade is its own monster that I have been considering next year.
Yakuza is more longer than Ace Combat.
Maybe we can do Ace Combat.
Yeah, I guess because Yakuza is like roleplay stuff and then... Or like, you know, like JRPG.
I guess you'd consider... Would you consider JRPG?
And then...
There's so many games.
Phantom Pain.
Don't worry, we'll do Phantom Pain again.
Probably.
Maybe with some mods.
Or something.
Armored Core?
I don't... I'm worried.
I'm worried about the backseaters.
There's always a Bugs Life.
Guys, I'm gonna become a full-time Bugs Life streamer.
Zone of the Enders.
Yeah, I do have that.
But Zone of the Enders... Wait, it's just Zone of the Enders 1 and 2, right?
I'm more thinking of like full-on series series type games.
Because, you know, I have those couples of series that are in my back pocket that are ones that will take a considerable amount of time.
So I went to... And I don't want to start so many things at once.
I kind of want to be like...
Okay, I finished this.
Now on to this.
I finished this.
More of a beat-em-up than an RPG?
Well, you're still role-playing as a Yakuza.
Unless, Nicholas, do you have something you want to tell us?
Escape from New York?
Maybe.
I didn't... I haven't watched Escape from LA, so...
Maybe one night we could do a double feature.
John Wick.
Oh yeah.
See, there's so many things.
If you play Ace Combat 7 again, I can be your target practice.
I appreciate it, Nan.
Well, I'm so sorry.
I really wanted to play up until the end.
But the PS2 says I'm tired, Minto.
And I have stuff I gotta do.
So I think I'm gonna take off, you guys.
I'm so sorry!
So sorry.
But thank you guys for going on this little nostalgia trip.
We got to at least see all the discs, so that's fun.
It was a lot of fun for me, too, to play the Emperor's New Groove again.
And... yeah.
Life of Bug.
You're gonna be changing berry covers like a pro.
Oh, it covers colors like a pro.
This OG side enjoyed it very much.
Also, Xenoblade X is its own separate game.
I didn't know that.
Thanks for the nostalgia trip, Minto.
Thank you!
This was a lot of fun!
Thank you guys for letting me...
And for joining me for this journey down the memory lane.
And hopefully you guys unlock some core memories, or some memories that you're like...
I forgot this game even existed!
So, that's always fun.
Right?
Maybe I'll get some more demo discs and we can do this in the future again, too.
With some different ones.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Anyway, thank you for putting up with my one guy nonsense.
You're all good!
Thank you!
Yeah!
Everybody,
thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
I'll see you guys when I see you next!
Bye bye!